the house will come to order members
take your seats
make sure we
my bed
the chair recognizes the member from
auburn representative osborne moves the
house adjourned from the session to may
4 2022. are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed day the eyes have it and
the house is adjourned the house will
attend to a prayer by house chaplain
reverend reverend bob stewart pastor
saint paul to the united methodist
church in manchester
thank you mr speaker
what a beautiful day in the neighborhood
different than yesterday
let us pray
o creator god we come together once
again to be about the business of this
great state of new hampshire
we pray that you would guide and direct
our discussions this day so that this
day is a fruitful day
almighty god i ask that you be with all
the leaders and representatives here
today
help each of us lead in a manner that is
acceptable to you oh god
oh god of love
we come to you with grateful hearts for
all the mothers amongst us this day and
we celebrate all the mothers that have
gone to be with you
god like a mother hand you long to
collect your chicks under your wings for
protection
o gracious god we are mindful that you
don't have to have children
to be a mother
we are reminded that one of the greatest
examples of a mother
mother teresa
she showed a mother's love to thousands
of people
and never gave birth
on this mother's day that we celebrate
this coming sunday
we pray for those for whom this day may
be difficult for various reasons
be with them and help them feel your
motherly presence
wrap your loving arms around them and
hold them close
o holy god you who are a shepherd of our
lives
help us to follow you to let go and let
you lead us in the right path
be with us oh god on each of our
journeys
whether we are high on a mountaintop or
deep in a valley
or anywhere in between
be with us and love us
protect us
lead us
comfort us
shepherd us
oh god each and every day of our lives
amen
chair recognizes the member from
hooksett representative michael
yakubovich who will lead us in the
pledge of allegiance
[Music]
individuals
chair recognizes max yakubovic for a
10th grade student at pinkerton academy
who will now sing our national anthem
can you see
by the dawn's
early light
what so
proudly we
hailed at the twilight's
last gleaming
whose broad stripes and bright stars
through the perilous
[Music]
were so gallantly
streaming
and the rockets
red glare
the bumps bursting
in air
gave proof
through the night
that our flag was still there
oh say
does that star spangled
for the land of the free
and the
home of the break
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for
leaves of absence
mr speaker the day illness
representatives eamonn birch buras
cleaver elliott ellis freitas gay gorg
mary griffin hamlet heath kelsey kimball
langley lawton major pamonte janice
schmidt varney vincent
and white the day important business
representatives belanger amanda bolden
conley cody cross de palma herbert lane
leishman murphy suzanne smith snow
thompson trottier the day illness in the
family representative frost
these leaves of absence shall be ground
unless otherwise ordered by the house
house will attend to introduction of
guests
mr speaker please welcome brian haycock
from mount royal academy in sunapee our
page for the day
[Applause]
mr speaker please welcome marika
yakubovic wife of representative
yaakovic jessica grill guest of
representative andrew bolden colton and
grant scorupian guest of representative
power michael and susan french guests of
representative tanner charles and
eleanor rambo husband and daughter of
representative rambo they're with us in
the gallery today
welcome to the new hampshire house
[Applause]
the chair recognizes the member from
george's mills representative linda
tanner to give him moral remarks for the
former member from ennica the honorable
barbara french
thank you mr speaker i'd like anybody
that knew barbara that would like to
come up and stand with me
and also the representatives from
henniker
thank you
today we honor a former democratic
member of the house the honorable
barbara connor french of henniker who
passed away at the end of last month at
the age of 96
just a couple weeks short of her 97th
birthday
with us today in the gallery are her
daughter susan son michael and best
friends eileen kelly the honorable beth
rod and vindy
standing with me are some fellow
representatives who served with barbara
and her representatives from henniker
i had the good fortune to work with
barbara right off in my freshman term
when i helped with a continuing
resolution from her committee
recognizing the cadet nurses of world
war ii
and that resolution became my very first
floor speech
barbara had grown up in that generation
that we affectionately call
the greatest generation
they answered the call of their country
and accepted responsibilities for the
home front during world war ii even at
the young age that barbara was at at
that time
she knew people who had enlisted in the
cadet nurse nurses
at a time when college was not always an
option for women
barbara was accepted and graduated from
unh with a bachelor of science degree
she then went on to get a bsn degree in
new york city from the cornell
university hospital and started her
career there as a clinical nurse
she later followed up with a master in
education degree
nursing takes a special type of person
intelligent
strong
determined persistent
caring and compassionate
barbara was all that and more
in new hampshire her con her career
continued as head nurse and structure
head nurse instructor at the new
hampshire hospital
a new hampshire as a new hampshire child
welfare social worker
and a consultant for the new hampshire
department of education and drug
education
and then finally
for 27 years she was a school nurse in
the concord schools
she served also her community as a
member of the henniker planning board
she was active in the democratic party
and a member of the henna
peace community
she attended weekly peace vigils up to a
few weeks before her hospitalization
she served 20 years in this house
as the representative from henniker and
although she was vertically challenged
as i am
her voice was very strong and not to be
denied
she was a sponsor and co-sponsor of
numerous bills
too many to list
that were signed into law
these range from issues including as you
can imagine health care the environment
children
the well-being of children and family
and then a bill that was for sampling
beer and wine at farmers markets just
add variety
she took great pride in her work in the
creation of the new hampshire healthy
kids
corporation which provides health care
to thousands of new hampshire children
and the child and family resource
centers that support wellness and
primary care services for children and
family at the community level
barbara received many awards recognizing
her hard work advocacy and service which
includes recognition
awards from the national association of
school nurses
the new hampshire
national education association retired
educators award and the prestigious new
hampshire democratic party eleanor
roosevelt award
in her personal life she was concerned
with fitness and health and she loved to
swim she swam in her beloved lake
massacecum
and she would persist on a daily swim
well into october
as long as she was able to do that
as betty davis once said age old age is
not for sissies and barbara was not a
she bravely met aging with grace humor
daily physical activity and being
involved in current events
long after she retired from the house
several of us and i know
representative shurtleff was one of them
would get calls from barbara on a
regular basis who wanted more
information or updates on bills she was
following or to share her reaction and
especially her opinion
on current political news in our bills
she kept involved with the new hampshire
nurses association who actually created
a legislative advocacy award in her name
when election times rolled around
barbara was there to help give advice
and advocate for her local democratic
candidates
she was a force to be reckoned with
highly respected by those who knew and
worked with her and a dedicated fighter
for quality public education
wellness accessible and affordable
health care for all
protection of women's reproductive
rights and protection for the
environment
she worked to protect and provide those
in need the vulnerable the young and
elderly
we will miss her in this fight for a
better world for all of us
we have uh white roses on the
speaker's podium in remembrance of
barbara and also uh white rose is a
remembrance for nurses so we honor
nurses all the nurses that have been the
unsung heroes of the pandemic we're
going through
for most people i would end this eulogy
or this memorial with and rest in peace
it doesn't seem right for barbara
i think it should be godspeed barbara
because i know she won't rest
she'll be directing and keeping all
those angels on their toes and on tasks
your memory is a blessing thank you
mr speaker
may i ask that we put those remarks in
the permanent journal without objection
thank you
we all have a moment of silence for our
fallen colleague barbara french
thank you
committee on education to which was
referred senate bill 234
an act requiring student identification
cards to include the national suicide
prevention lifeline
house will be in order
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment it's in a brick
ladder for the committee the amendment
is
h printed in house record 17 page 56.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it in the amendment is
adopted
the motion before us now is how to pass
with amendment the chair recognized
representative rick ladd
thank you very much mr speaker
and colleagues i also would like to
thank our young man from pinkerton
academy today that was a wonderful
rendition of our national anthem
i'm here to speak in support of
sb 234
now to be known as the jason dickey
suicide prevention act
within your committee report you'll note
that there's some statistics on suicide
in our country i'm not going to go into
that you can read that just as well as i
can say it
but one thing we are the second leading
the second leading cause of death
amongst those that are ages 10 through
34 in our country
is suicide
this bill
will address the issue of suicide
issues amongst our young people here in
the state of new hampshire
it's not a complete
and thorough way to
answer this problem but it's one solid
step forward
for those schools which issue id cards
for students be it a
elementary school through a secondary
school or post-secondary institution in
our state when the id card is issued
on the back side the national suicide
prevention lifeline will be printed
there on the back of that card
with the new number there's a 1 800
number but the new number
988 which will go in effect july 16
for folks to call in case of
a need and there are needs in this state
why this
what does the suicide prevention hotline
or lifeline provide it provides
prevention of resources it provides
mental health services and it provides a
live voice for one to talk with
in such a awful situation in a possible
tragedy
during the committee hearing
i was very pressed in fact overwhelmed
with the deep and sincere
presentation
by jason's parents
to quote
his mother
martha
my hope is of
is if one student in new hampshire has
the number
and sees it one day that number in the
backside that card
and makes that call
and saves themselves
that's a success
it's truly a success
will this act make a difference my
answer is yes it will
this bill provides hope
when you open that door from
hopelessness
and meet hope
and you meet the light of day
that's what we need to have available to
those that are looking at this awful end
during the committee hearing process
we heard that jason
was very politically oriented
and perhaps with the passage of this
bill
another young person with another
similar dream
may fully
have that dream
come
to be
and perhaps even sit in this chamber
someday
instead of taking that tragic route of
suicide
so in conclusion
i'd like to say this on behalf of the
entire education committee the committee
the whole
we were humbled and honored to hear the
testimony of the parents
we are humbled and honored to present
this bill to the general court and i ask
your support thank you
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on senate bill 2 3 4.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
up in the gallery
we have paul and martha dickey
who are with us
we want to thank you for your leadership
in getting this bill passed
[Applause]
for what reason does a member rise um
could we put i request that the remarks
of the previous speaker be put in the
permanent journal without objection
majority of the committee on judiciary
two which was referred senate bill 216
enact establishing a commission to study
the landlord attendant mediation program
in circuit courts consider the same
report the same with the following
resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate representative kurt walper for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass to
charlotte d lorenzo for the minority of
the committee
the motion before us is the in motion of
inexpedient to legislate are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
there's opposed nay
the eyes haven't the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on judiciary
to which was referred senate bill 217
act relative to eviction notices having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senator
michael silvia for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
sent charlotte dilorenzo for the
minority of the committee the motion
before us is the motion of inexpedient
to legislate are you ready for the
question all those
division has been requested members will
take their seats
make sure your voting stations are on
[Music]
so
drink
members will take their seats this will
be a division vote
motion before us is the majority report
have been expedient to legislate the
house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative
alexander for a parliamentary inquiry
he's waving off
the motion before us is the majority
committee report have been expedient to
legislate on senate bill 217 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
okay
represent bradley
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
178 voting a 140 voting a committee
reporters adopted
senator baxter declared a conflict of
interest and did not participate
majority of the
majority of the committee on judiciary
two which was referred senate bill 2-2-2
when act pre-emitting licensing boards
to conduct remote meetings having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senator kurt
walper for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
representative rebecca macbeth for the
minority of the committee the motion
before us is inexpedient to legislate on
senate bill 2-2-2 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
where's the paul's name
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
okay
majority of the committee on judiciary
to which was referred senate bill 302 fn
an act establishing the personal privacy
protection act having considered the
same report the same the following
amendment the recommendation of the bill
auto password amendment senator mark
mclean for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative rebecca
macbeth for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is 1443h printed in house
record 17 page 65. are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye
here's opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee amendment
is adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on judiciary
two which was referred senate bill 339
enact relative to meeting of boards and
commissions in the department of safety
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpensive to
legislate senator louise andres for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
amendments diane langley for the
minority of the committee the motion
before us is the inexpedient to
legislative motion on senate bill 339
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
there's opposed nay
the eyes have it and committee report is
adopted
majority committee on judiciary to which
has referred senate bill 344 an act
relative to the electronic participation
requirements of meetings open to the
public under the right to no law
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is in expedient to legislate
representative kurt walper for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative rebecca
macbeth for the minority of the
committee the motion before us is the
motion been expedient to legislate on
senate bill 344 are you ready for the
question harlow
a roll call has been requested as a that
is sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
[Music]
thanksgiving
house will come to order
the motion before us is the
majority report of innings leading to
legislative senate bill 344. this is a
roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
sylvia for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that our constitution demands
transparency when i press a green button
the motion before us the majority
committee report have been explaining
the legislate on senate bill 344 this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you
post or press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
house will be in order
we're in the voting mode and nobody was
signed up
voting stations
representative d silvestro
is something wrong with your station all
right we'll take a look thank you
thank you
representative
yes or no
thank you
representative
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
176 voting a 155 voting a the committee
report is adopted
committee on judiciary to which was
referred senate bill 388 and act
relative to availability of information
or records relating to the enhanced
9-1-1 system considered the same report
the same with the recommendation the
bill ought to pass and a current walper
for the majority of the committee
chair recognizes representative gordon
mr speaker i rise to make a motion
state your motion
i moved to table senate bill 388
and i request a division
that is a correct motion
the motion is to table senate bill 388
and a division has been requested
members will take their seats
the motion before us is to table
senate bill 388
this is a division vote chair recognizes
representative gordon for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
i if i know
that enhanced
of 911 information about all of us
in order to carry out its functions
and
it is very valuable to many people
if i also know
that
that information is intended to remain
private it is not available to the
public
and we have in the past as the
legislature
made it unavailable to the public and
only limited the limited available and
given that only limited availability to
law enforcement
and in one circumstance to the
department of health and human services
to determine the location of wells and
water lines to address pollution issues
and if i know this bill
was asked by the insurance department to
have access
to that
treasure trove of information
and
if
i also know that the
the
judiciary committee wanted to
accommodate
the insurance department
and
grant them a request for the information
they requested which was the nature and
the timing of telephone calls
and limited to that only
and so
if i know this was put on the calendar
as ought to pass with the idea that we
would have a floor amendment
specifying or limiting their ability to
have access to that information
and finally if i know that when the
insurance department found out the
access was limited
they were very unhappy
they wanted unfettered access
including the ability to have access to
listen to and receive copies of
telephone calls
without going through law enforcement or
getting a warrant
and
so
therefore
uh i believe that the committee feels
it this this is a parliamentary
representative yes
and and finally
and finally having said all that
mr speaker
if if if i know that the
the department said they'd rather have
nothing
than to have the amendment which was
going to be proposed by the committee
right
what would i want to give the insurance
department their grant their insurance
department their wish and
place this on the table and press the
green button thank you
the motion before us is the motion to
table on senate bill 388 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
for the green ones
[Music]
representative grassy
all members president an opportunity to
vote also attend the state of the road
327 voting yay two voting a
committee the motion to table
house will be in order
jury day committee on judiciary to which
was referred senate bill 292
an act establishing a commission to
study insanity and restoration of
competency considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate representative troy murder
from the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative alexis simpson from
the minority of the committee the motion
before us is the
majority committee reported been
expedient to legislative and senate bill
392 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the
committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on labor
industrial and real data services which
to which was referred to senate bill 209
act relative to electronic wage payments
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative michael cahill from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority
complete the following amendment
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
senator william infantine for the
minority of the committee
the motion before us is the majority
committee report
of interim study on senate bill 209
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on labor
industrial and related services to which
was referred senate bill 345 and act
relative to youth employment
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment some brian c with
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same be an unknown degree
with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate president of
janice smith for the minority of the
committee
majority amendment is 1607 age printed
in house record 17 page 71. are you
ready for the question on the
amendment
all those in favor say aye
as it calls nay
[Music]
the eyes have it in the
majority amendment is adopted the bills
on second reading opened a further
amendment
president sullivan office amendment 1705
h
printed in house record 17 page 71.
and the chair recognizes representative
seaworth
oh i'm sorry
representative sullivan offers his four
amendments
and recognized to speak
thank you mr speaker
the
committee amendment that we just passed
deals with youth night work these are 16
and 17 year old kids
and what that amendment did was it
repealed any limitation on night work
for those kids
i'm a parent many of you are parents
some of you will be parents
um and i think we all care about kids
and frankly
having no limitation on night work for
16 and 17 year olds
is just
it's a big step too far
i can imagine
an employer
coming to a 16 year old and saying look
we've got a major restocking we've got
to do tonight
i'm going to ask you to stay late
really late
and
complete the restocking and if you can't
make it to school tomorrow it's just one
day
and they can do that as often as they
need to or want to
without limitation
i think that's a big step too far
the amendment that i propose
replaces
the current very confusing limitation on
night work for 16 and 17 year olds
or currently a lot of employers because
it's so confusing they limit their
uh 16 to 17 year olds to working in
until only eight o'clock
because there's a very convoluted i'm
not going to try to explain it because
it ain't worth it um one way or the
other we're gonna replace this
um
i propose that we do put a reasonable
limit on night work on school nights
my amendment
proposes the following language
night work
no youth which is a 16 or 17 year old by
definition
shall be permitted to work later than 9
p.m on any day when the day following is
a school day
or later than 12 a.m
on any other day
that means
during the summer they can work until
midnight
if the following day is a holiday they
can work until midnight
if it's a school vacation week they can
work until midnight
if it's
christmas vacation week
midnight
if there's school tomorrow
they have to be done working by nine
nine pm
i think it's reasonable
as a parent
i would
want that type of limitation for a 16 or
17 year old and i ask you to support
this amendment
and mr speaker i ask for a division vote
thank you
chair recognized representative seaworth
thank you mr speaker i
i rise in opposition to this floor
amendment on sb 345.
mr speaker i noticed that some of my
colleagues here
know what the s stands for for i
can't seem to keep track of that myself
what i do know mr speaker
is that we tend to get this rush of
these sb bills
right at the end of session
and and they're put together in a
different way than we would put together
bills here in the house
for example
a lot of times these sb bills have a
number of provisions in them that could
easily be
separate laws but they tend to get
lumped together into a single bill
um
part of doing this seems to be that they
come together in this lump
to build a consensus
and sometimes sometimes
it seems like there are last
provisions shoved into a bill to build
that consensus
and mr speaker i think all of these
replies
this is on the amendment this is on the
amendment yes
because
this amendment
changes multiple pieces
of this senate bill
and i want to point out that there are
multiple pieces to change
she wants to talk to her
this this i just remind the member again
this is on the amendment alone yes of
course not not on the senate bill itself
thank you
um
so
the issue with this bill as it came to
us and why it needed to be amended
is
that
this is a bill is being amended correct
yes
so all right
this amendment has
serious
technical problems we we heard a little
bit about the the debate on
policy
but beyond that debate on policy
the language that's before us is
unworkable
um
i'll go through just one of the issues
and
the the amendments in the calendar you
can you can take a look at this if you
want i'll try to explain it
so let's just go to section two in the
floor amendment
and what this deals with is a different
provision than what the previous speaker
talked about
this is a section of current law
that sets up the limit
to the number of hours that a teen can
work
during a week
which sounds simple enough
we can understand that the problem is
it's in this multi-tiered set of
restrictions
so if you're 15 years old
and school is in session there's one
limit
if you're 15 years old and school is not
in session it's the summer there's
another limit
and this is in section two of the
amendment that i'm referring to
if you're 16 and 17 years old and school
is in session for five days
there's a limit for that
if it's four days there's a limit for
that if there's three two or one we'll
lump that together there's a limit for
that
if it's zero days there's a separate
limit
and if it
is a 16 or 17 year old who is no longer
duly enrolled in school so they've
graduated there's another limit for that
if you look at the amendment
it does a good thing that we all agree
to it crosses out some of that
complication
but it goes a little too far if you look
at all the things that are crossed out
one of the things that it crosses out is
when this provision is applicable
leaving what's left in the amended
language to apply generally
in other words
what it does is
for
a 17 year old during the summer
if we adopt the language in this meant
amendment
is now restricted to working fewer hours
than a 15 year old can work during the
summer
i don't believe listening to the
explanation that this was the intent of
this bill
i think it's purely a technical issue
with how the language was put together
and i think it's a serious problem if we
adopt this
i can go on mr speaker i know
i know nobody wants me to so i'll stop
with that and just say
we cannot adopt this amendment due to
errors in the language i ask that you
reject this amendment and we move to an
up or down vote on the underlying bill
thank you mr speaker does the member
yield to questions
so i'm sure what you may inquire
thank you mr speaker i thank the member
for taking my question
uh with reference that you made to
having a
large spate of senate bills to deal with
uh i noticed that your committee only
got four senate bills and i'm wondering
why is it that your committee didn't
have time
to perfect the language and clarify it
for just the instances that you were
addressing why didn't you have that time
thank you mr speaker and the question
seems to be on other actions we took on
this bill in committee which i was asked
not to speak about so i i don't think i
can answer that
does a member yield to further questions
yes
okay here may inquire
thank you mr speaker and thank you mr
seaworth my good friend from labor
with whom we've served several terms
together
this is a complicated
bill that we're trying to correct
and and i believe my colleague has done
a wonderful job in correcting this issue
uh to the in in the spirit of the way
that the other body sent it to us which
i in this case i agree with
i don't always agree with the other body
but this time they did a good job almost
so
is it not true that what we're trying to
do here is protect the
the long-term interests the possible you
know educational outcomes and careers of
our stu of our high school students
while they're working
but only by limiting their hours during
the school year
when they have school the next day so
that they will not be
uh working and driving home at late
hours and risking their future
you know for the
problem
excuse me i mean we all have we all have
most of us have kids some of us you know
have grandkids and maybe we'd like to
have them get a good education and make
the best of their lives
this is this is important you know so
and i appreciate the restaurant industry
needing help but there's help available
and they can they can do it
they don't have to have the t the case
is is it not true that kids can do a
good job until nine o'clock in the
school representative it is a question
yes three and we're recognized for a
question thanks sir is it not true that
the restaurant industry will benefit
from having these kids there until nine
o'clock
and isn't that not sufficient to meet
their needs and the needs of our
students
respectfully well
those are admirable intentions
that's not what the language of this
amendment said and that's why i asked
the chamber to vote it down
does the member yield a further question
remember does not yield please read the
amendment
the motion before us
is the sullivan floor amendment
roll call has been requested
and tim smith is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
so
do you want
it all right
with
household come to water
the motion before us is the
sullivan floor amendment this is a roll
call vote
chair recognized representative sullivan
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that this amendment is really really
simple
and if i know that all it's intended to
do
is to keep 16 and 17 year old kids
from working very late on a school night
if i further know
that this amendment will also allow
those kids to work until midnight on
days when there's not school on the next
day
would i then press the green button to
protect our kids from abuse in the
workplace thank you
the chair recognized representative
proud for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that if adopted this amendment
would make our laws stricter
than they are today and force
existing
youths that are working a schedule now
to abandon that
schedule and if i also know that because
of the interaction of the various
sections of the law what this amendment
would do is make the rules for 16 and 17
year olds stricter than the rules for 14
and 15 year olds
and if i also know the department the
way the department has uh
interpreted the phrase enrolled in
school in this amendment would include
the summer
which i don't believe was the intent
would i now press the red button and
vote no on this amendment
the motion before us is the sullivan
floor amendment
1705 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
of your polls you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
154 voting yay 181 voting
the sullivan floor amendment fails
for what reason did member rise
mr speaker i would move that senate bill
345 be placed upon the table i'd
requested a division vote and would like
to give api
a roll call has been requested is that
that is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote the motion is to lay
senate bill 345 on the table
so
the motion before us is is to lay senate
bill 345 on the table
this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognized representative tim
smith for parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker
if i know that this is not the 1830s
and if for the life of me i cannot
figure out why on earth this chamber
would seek to alleviate
an artificial and temporary labor
shortage by backfilling empty shifts
with child labor where i press the green
button
the house will be in order
chair recognizes
oh boy
[Music]
the house will be in order
please
now the chair will recognize
representative infantine for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know there's
many things in this bill
that need to be discussed
and that the
intent of the bill was not to do what
was just previously stated by any means
that would i ask my colleagues to vote
against the tailing motion so you can
hear the debate on a very important
piece of legislation thank you mr
speaker
motion before us is the late senate bill
345 on the table it's a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you post press the red
button voting spaces are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative sandler
thank you
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
145 voting a 192 voting a
tabling motion fails
now we're back to the majority committee
report of auto pass as amended
on senate bill 345
chair recognizes representative sullivan
speak against the committee report
representative sullivan is waving off
the chair recognizes representative
seaworth
president seaworth is waving off
are you ready for the question
who will request
who requested a roll call
that is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote
motion before us as the majority report
of auto pass says amendment this is a
roll call vote chair recognized
representative adjunct for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that as a member of
the committee on labor
when i heard this bill introduced
one of the things that i heard from
every single person who testified in
support was well we have a labor
shortage
and if i know that between
moving the hours that children can work
and cutting enhanced unemployment
benefits the single thing in my lifetime
that the federal government has done to
advance the material well-being of
people in times of crisis
it seems we will do everything to plug
this temporary low-wage worker shortage
other than actually paying people what
they need to be paid to do these jobs
would i now vote no on the motion of ota
otpa so that this bill can be defeated
thank you
chair recognized representative
infantine for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the current law is
confusing to both parents and employers
and if i know that the liquor commission
has agreed with one of the changes to
this law allowing younger employees to
be able to bust tables that might have
an alcoholic drink on them
if i further know that while no bill is
perfect this bill as amended offers a
balance between younger employees that
need to work for financial reasons
those who will work for extra
money
the
ability of parents and students
themselves to make the decisions while
keeping the government
out of those decisions
if i know all of this would i please
support the majority of the committee
and press the green button
the motion before us is the majority
report of what a pass had amended on
senate bill 345 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your polls you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
falmer was president had an opportunity
to vote
house will tend to stay to the vote
185 voting yay 152 voting a the
committee report is adopted
you you can't make a motion from your
chair
what reason does the member rise i move
that the remarks of the previous debate
be placed in the permanent journal
we will put it to a vote
i had a request for a division i'm not
sure where but i did hear a division
vote
this will be a division vote on whether
the remarks will be
is that a roll call
the house will be in order
there's been a request for a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote to print whether to
print the remarks in the permanent
journal
so
yeah
the motion before us is to print the
remarks in the permanent journal on the
debate on senate bill 345.
it's a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if your
polls will press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
representative
baltimore mr president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
164 voting a 172 vote in a the motion to
print the remarks
fails
the house will be in order
for what reason does a member rise
a question of the chair
state your question thank you mr speaker
is it not true that all of our debates
here are available online after today
yes thank you
majority of the committee on labor
industrial related data services to
which was referred senate
bill
377 fn
an act relative to the eligibility of
certain inquiries injuries of state
troopers for workers compensation have
extended the same report the same the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study center of liberal
avellini for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative
brian sullivan from the minority of the
committee
question before us is the majority
committee report of interim study are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye those opposed nay
the eyes haven't committed reporters
adopted
committee on municipal and county
government which was referred senate
bill 239 fn enact relative to
non-compliance with municipal audit
requirements having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
senator richard lasellis for the
committee
the motion before us is the
committee report about a pass are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on municipal
county government to which was referred
senate bill 245 an act establishing a
committee to study agreements between
developers and municipalities on
municipal trash removal fees
paid by condominium owners and renters
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment the
recommendation of bill ought to pass
with amendment
president
majipudi for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate
represent a rigid trip for the minority
of the committee
the amendment is one four five two h
printed in house record 17 pages 56-57
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
a
division of division i am a little in
doubt i will have a division vote on
this
members in the room only nobody can else
can come in
so
the motion before us is to on the
amendment one four five two h
this is a division vote for
clarification
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
here
so
all members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend state of the vote
140 voting 866 voting a committee
amendment fails
for what reason is a member rise
thank you mr speaker to make a motion
stage in motion
i make a motion to table senate bill
245.
that is a proper motion
the motion before us is the table senate
bill 245
are you ready for the question
the vision has been requested this will
be a division vote
on the motion to table senate bill 245
members take your seats
is
where
the motion before us is his table senate
bill 245 chair recognizes representative
dolan for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this is a study
commission between developers and
municipalities
and if i know that this
will be best left to the parties to
resolve on the local level then wouldn't
i press
the red button
green but sorry green button
to table
chair recognize representative gallagher
for parliamentary inquiries
if i
uh believe that the issue of
trash collection agreements
between
renters and
municipalities
is an important one that deserves our
full consideration and a vote on the
underlying bill
then would i then press
the red button so that we can not table
this and
move on to a full vote
motion before us is the table senate
bill 245.
it's the division vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative simpson is representative
petrigno in his seat
thank you
representative wolf
all members president opportunity to
vote also attend the state of the vote
187 voting 148 voting nay
senate bill 245 is laid on the table
majority of committee on municipal and
county government jewish was referred
senate bill 246 and act relative to
qualified private communities having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution solved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator tony
pamonte for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered this ambient edible degree
with the majority report the
recommendation that bill ought to pass
senator laura stavis for the minority of
the committee
the chair recognizes representatives for
speak against the committee report
[Music]
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker tens of thousands of new
hampshire citizens live in what sb 246
calls private qualified communities
often these are developments with dozens
of homes and many miles of roads
sidewalks and other general
infrastructure including sewer systems
open space and runoff drainage systems
outside of these communities
municipalities shoulder the burden of
maintaining the kind of infrastructure
but in so-called private communities
homeowners themselves are responsible
for these expenses
in addition to paying property taxes at
the same rate as their neighbors on
public streets
to be sure buying into such a community
is a choice
and most people understand that they
will have to subsidize certain services
that are normally addressed
by cities and towns
that is not the issue here
the issue is one of time
time sufficient for a community to build
up the kind of capital reserves that
will inevitably need be needed when it's
time to pave roads and repair retaining
walls
sb 246 gives communities that time
in requiring developers to deposit funds
in escrow that would cover 50 percent of
the community's road repair expenses
should those roads fail earlier than
expected
this bill also gives developers and
planning boards a choice
to substitute that escrow amount with a
guarantee that community roads will be
built to municipal standards
providing extra assurance that they will
not fail prematurely and potentially
bankrupt the homeowners in the community
sb 246 would help new hampshire in other
ways as well
at a time when more and more new homes
are being built in such communities
new hampshire continues to be one of
only a few states in the nation with no
body of law that specifically addresses
homeowners associations
developing that legislation is very much
overdue in our state and sb 246 gives us
an excellent starting point
homeowners associations and communities
like them
need two things at this moment
new ones need time to establish strong
capital reserve funds
sb 246 gives them that
and they need real recognition by the
state as entities that require new
thinking and new legislation to guide
their development and ensure that they
remain a viable segment of the housing
market
i urge you to support the minority of
municipal and county government and pass
this bill thank you mr speaker
chair recognized representative dolan
thank you mr speaker
senate bill 246
is a bill that will establish a new role
for qualified
private communities
a qualified private community would
consist of a community trust
or other trust device
a condominium association homeowners
association
road association or council of co-owners
where the cost of maintaining roads
streets
water and sewer infrastructure and
providing essential services is paid for
by a not-for-profit entity consisting
exclusively of unit owners within the
community
one of the main issues is the disclosure
of the purchase agreement originally
established for example
the roads are shared and used by all
members
of the community
the roads were created
less than the normal width
in many cases to lower the price of a
house lot and also the house itself
to introduce legislation to have a
developer put money into escrow to
maintain that road would just drive the
price of the house higher
and
with the shortage of affordable housing
in new hampshire
the committee minority i've said
majority felt this would just raise the
prices in new hampshire and make them
even less affordable
the motion before us is
the majority report of inexpensive to
legislate on senate bill 246.
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
so
oh
i made a mistake
members will be in their seats this is a
division vote
the motion before us is the majority
reported in expedia to legislate on
senate bill 246.
the chair recognizes representative
magliore for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker colleagues
if i know
that having a road of proper width
is vital for the safety of a community
and if i further know that the expense
of repairing
roads is enormous
and if i also know
that members of the residents who live
in qualified private communities are
paying for the repair of roads
throughout their communities and their
taxes
do not necessarily get the same benefit
themselves
would i then vote against
the motion of an expedient to legislate
so that a different motion can be made
thank you
chair recognized representative dolan
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know condo owners often pay taxes
to a municipality but services are
limited
and if i know
this is the agreement
often established as the units are being
built
and if i know this will shift
tax payments away from condo owners
and if i know that maintaining the roads
will need to be added to town
responsibility
and taxpayer cost while the roads are
often substandard
then wouldn't i press the green button
to support the itl
a motion before us is a majority
committee reported in expediential
legislative senate bill 246. this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your post will
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
183 voting yeah 146 voting a the
committee report is adopted
so
right
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government which
was referred senate bill 329
an act establishing a commission to
study barriers to housing development in
new hampshire including workforce and
middle-income housing having considered
the same report the same with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative
richard tripp for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is in
expedience of legislate representative
laurel stavis from the minority of the
committee the committee amendment is
1828h
printed on house record 17 on pages
68-69
the questions on the committee amendment
a division has been requested this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
members should be in their seats
the house will come to order and members
should be in their seats
thank you
the question is whether to adopt
amendment 1828h representative maggiore
is recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker thank you
colleagues
if i if i know
that studying the barriers to housing
housing
housing is the most important issue that
we have one of the most important issues
and priority issues in this state if i
know
that that is
vital to the work that we do here in the
house
then what i press yet would i press the
green button and vote in favor
of the otp of the amendment thank you
right that else will be in order so now
that i have your attention
amend that
to vote no and hit the red button thank
you
and that's why we ask the question
representative powers recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that manufactured
in 3d printed housing may provide
affordable housing options for new
hampshire
and as such should be included in the
commission
to study barriers to housing development
in the state
and if i also know that a super majority
tax cap
override
as enabling legislation
is a common sense measure for taxpayers
to effectively manage local spending to
keep their taxes under control
and to in fact make housing more
affordable in the granite state
would i now vote yes to support this
floor amendment
and push the green button thank you
this is the committee amendment
the question is whether to adopt
amendment 1828
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent myler
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
171 on the affirmative 152 in the
negative the amendment is adopted
the question now is on the majority
committee report of ought to pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
foreign
so
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county governments which
was referred to sb 400 fm an act
relative to training and procedures for
zoning and planning boards and relative
to financial investments and incentives
for affordable housing development
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment representative
richard lacelles for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolve
that it is in expedient to legislate
representative ivy van for the minority
of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
for a motion mr speaker state your
motion i moved to table hospital for
senate bill 400.
representative welper moves to tables
senate bill 400
may speak to my motion
no that's not debatable
all right
so the
motion is to table senate bill 400 are
you ready for the question and our
division vote's been requested this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
well we will mean the same
okay
the house will come to order the
question is whether the table senate
bill 400 representative welker is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know this bill
would effectively destroy
local zoning
and if i know
this bill would force
encourage
many districts in our state
to
enact
to allow
developments in contravention of their
master plans
and if i know that would force them
to subsidize those things at the expense
of those people that already lived there
would i now vote to table this bill
representative umberger is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that housing
housing
is the realtor's word for problems in
this state
if i know that we had teachers in my
school district
that couldn't
find a place to live
and had to
not accept the job
if i know the policemen the firemen
the municipal workers
cannot afford the housing
in many of our communities
mine included
would i now please
push the red button
so that we can get on with trying to do
something positive
for our workers
thank
you the question is whether to table sb
400 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
of all members presidents had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
170 in the affirmative 159 on the
negative the house will be in order
senate bill 400 is laid on the table
the majority of the committee on
resources recreation and development
which was referred senate bill 258 fn
local an act relative to the graves of
african americans alive during the
period of american enslavement having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative greg hoff for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative bruce cohen the question
is on the majority committee report of
referred for interim study are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
division has been requested this will be
a division vote members take your seats
okay
the house will come to order
the question is on the majority
committee report of referred for interim
study on sb 258
representative huff is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry he's waived off as
well okay if you're in favor of interim
study you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
we're in the voting mode
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
180 in the affirmative 146 and the
negative the committee report is adopted
representative ward declared a conflict
of interest and did not participate
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred senate bill 259 an act relative
to the definition of municipal host for
purposes of limited electrical energy
producers having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill be referred for interim
study representative j.d bernardi for
the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative lee
oxenham for the minority of the
committee
the question is on the majority
committee report of interim study are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
reports adopted
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred senate bill 263 an act
establishing the new hampshire youth
environmental education and conservation
council having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
fred platt for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative jacqueline
cali pitts for the minority of the
committee
representative callie pitts is
recognized to speak against the
committee report
i promise i'll only take three minutes
i wasn't going to really speak at all
but we just had
a youth
bill where we asked the youth to do more
work
physical work
now we have a bill where youth from 12
to 25 have come to us
asking us
for to legitimize a youth council
a youth council that will talk and
consult with
the speaker
with the house with the senate
on conservation matters
and that's very important
these are the people coming up i'm too
old to be here
these are young people can you suspend
from that you can say okay
representative kelly fez can you hang on
for a sec i see like eight conversations
going on let's take those out to the
interim so that we can hear the member
and you don't look too old to me
representative
the youth council is very important this
council would only meet quarterly
it would ask for us for advice
which is admirable in our youth
they will ask us for guidance and they
will give us their thoughts on what we
need to do for the future of our state
this council will cost
the state
zero
i for one
would volunteer if they wanted me
to meet with them quarterly
i think this is a very good idea this is
a step forward
now we have other youth groups that are
involved
but this one is very important they're
going to talk about energy they're going
to talk about the future that they see
not necessarily that i or we see
this cost nothing
i would ask you to please overturn the
committee report
give this council a chance
these children
and i call them children because i'm
again old
they
were
so eloquent
in their appeal
it i think it dazzled most of us
they asked us for help
they asked us for guidance
they asked us for legitimacy
legitimize their efforts now they can
all do this alone on the schools
but isn't it wonderful if all of them
from all parts of the state
can get together
and share their ideas equally
please
give this youth council a chance thank
you
representative plett was recognized to
speak in support of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
this
is an aspirational committee
but it doesn't need government to form
it it can form if the kids want to get
together talk about environment and so
on they can already
exists in law they're already existing
in our new hampshire legislative youth
advisory council it's rsa 19k1
they can take up this issue we don't
need another committee thank you
the questions on the majority committee
report of
an expediency legislate are you ready
for the question
roll call has been requested by
who requested the roll call
right there
and it is sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call vote
i also come to order members please find
your seats
the questions on the majority committee
report of inexpedience are legislated
representative partial is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker
if i know that pierre tell her
chardan stated
that the future belongs to those who
give
the next generation reason for hope let
me repeat that
the future belongs to those who give the
next generation reason for hope
and if i know we had the future visit
our committee in the form of several
students
that advocated for a voice in setting
the very policies that will affect them
then would i not now push the red button
to defeat this itl
and provide them a seat at the table
that rightfully belongs to them
thank you
representative thomas is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know there are many many
youth groups in this state
and not all of them
are need to be formed by legislation
if i also know
that
we already have a youth council that has
been set forth by statute and that many
organizations including the one under
under consideration here can come to
them with their ideas and advice and
that counsel could be brought forth to
the legislature
like the council currently does
if i know all this
then would you please press the green
button to support
the committee's recommendation of itl
thank you
the questions on the majority committee
report of inexpedience a legislate this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
representative eaton
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
174 in the affirmative 150 on the
negative the committee reports adopted
the committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred senate bill
271 an act relative to the burgess
biopower facility having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with amendment
representative michael vos for the
committee
take two
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred senate bill 269
okay
an act establishing a commission to
study energy saving weatherization
programs having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill be referred for interim
study representative jose campbell's for
the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative peter samsuch for
the minority of the committee
the question is on the majority
committee report of interim study are
you ready for the question
the division has been requested a roll
call has been requested is there some
request a roll call
so
the member from portsmouth
representative sampson is recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you
thank you mr speaker honorable members
of the house
i rise to oppose the interim study for
sb 269.
this is a pretty
simple bill it calls for a
commission
to study the best practices for
weatherization
if you're like me and you listen to the
10 o'clock news in the evening on a
certain local channel
you will hear a commercial very often
played
by a company not named here but that
says are you cold in the winter are you
warm in the summer
your problem is not that you need a new
house but you need better insulation
and this is what this commission would
do this commission would try to look for
the best practices to weatherize your
home to make it as efficient as possible
thereby driving down the demand for
energy in your house
now
when it comes to paying money
you don't want to pay more money to heat
your house than you have to so if you
release your demand
that's a good thing
now that means you don't need as much
supply
it doesn't matter how efficient your
furnace is or your air conditioning is
if your house is a leaky house
it's an inefficient house and you're
wasting energy and you're wasting money
so this bill basically just says let's
look at weatherization uh programs and
let's see what the best opportunities to
minimize your energy costs and save
dollars as well
and it will come up with recommendations
and when those recommendations come out
we can always say no to the
recommendations we don't need to accept
them
so that is the thrust of this of this
particular bill and i think it's a good
bill
and
i ask you to override the
the motion of interim study so that a
different motion can be made and i and
mr speaker i ask for a roll call vote
please
the member from loudoun representative
campbell is recognized to speak in
support of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
and i would just like to say what an
honor it is for me to be able to address
this body for the very first time
[Applause]
the previous speaker mentioned uh this
bill attempts to establish a commission
to study the energy-saving
weatherization programs
but uh what the majority of the ste
committee found
is that this bill should be referred to
interim study the reason for that is
that during the testimony
there were many concerns one of which
was
it was in regards to the unbalanced
member makeup of the commission there
were also concerns about language that
said that they would be reducing the
contractor pre-qualifications
we need to know what that would mean
and the costs associated with
administrating that process
additionally this policy
uh direction
is said to that they would explore
expanding the fiscal participation of
propane and oil users in new hampshire
this needs to be better understood
because we're already at an all-time
at all-time high energy prices we
certainly don't need any more fees to be
added
uh our citizens are paying enough as it
is so i would ask that you would
support the committee recommendation to
interim study this bill thank you
the questions on the majority committee
report of interim study this is a roll
call vote members please take your seats
yes
when he was about to blow by there were
about 50 people okay
the questions on the majority committee
report of referred for interim study
this is a roll call vote representative
man is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
um
if i know that this decision was made at
the
committee meeting without any discussion
whatsoever
and so does not represent
the considered opinion of the science
and technology committee
and if i also
know that the senate bill 269 as amended
creates a process for a broad-based
and factual
operational and financial basis
for making investments in energy
efficiency
and for identifying opportunities to
stem the enormous waste
of our citizens hard-earned money
to buy way more fuel
than they ought to be necessary
would i now press
the red button to defeat the
the motion thank you
representative vos is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that there are
many
active and functioning weatherization
programs in the state currently
the biggest of which you probably have
heard of it's called new hampshire saves
and if i further know that this bill's
real intention
was to figure out a way to get oil and
propane users to pay
for energy efficiency programs
adding to the cost of our electricity
would i now press the green button to
support the committee recommendation
thank you mr speaker
the questions on the committee report of
referred for interim study this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
represent bradley
representative mann
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend on the state of
the vote
182 in the affirmative 152 in the
negative the committee reports adopted
for what reason does a member rise
a question of the speaker
pursued
mr speaker during the uh pi in the last
debate
did not one of the persons giving the pi
suggest that there were certain motives
behind a bill that were not part of the
bill
and if so does that not contrary to our
practice and precedent in this house
where we do not ascribe motive to any
other person
i didn't catch that happening but you
are correct that we never do that in
this chamber
the committee on science technology
energy which was referred senate bill
271 an act relative to the burgess
biopower facility having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment at the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
the committee amendment is 1788h
printed on house records 17 can be found
on page 59. are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
reports adopted that was a squeaker
the bill is open is on second reading
and opened a further amendment
representative samsung offers floor
amendment
1894h which you can find in your seat
pockets and is recognized to speak to
his amendment
thank you mr speaker and thank you
honorable members of the house
i ask you to reject
the committee recommendation and
amendment on h.b 271.
uh this amendment calls for only a
12-month reprieve of the current
financial situation of the burgess
biopower plant
while a better long-term solution is
being developed
[Music]
yes
thank you
thank you for that clarification so i'm
i'm speaking on behalf of the amendment
i proposed
and this amendment
contrary to the previous one we just
heard
does something different for long term
for the burgess power plant
the majority amendment provides only a
temporary solution
for the operation of the burgess power
plant
it is a mainstay of the regional economy
and an essential component of new
hampshire's in-state renewable energy
assets
committee members were in agreement that
a well-designed
long-term solution is needed
however the majority
only provides a 12-month reprieve
preempting the work of a commission from
the natural resources committee which is
currently tasked with addressing the
overarching issue of the long-term
sustainability of our new hampshire
timber industry
12 months is in my opinion not enough to
avoid a shutdown of this facility
few businesses when given a 12-month
extension of their financial situation
would start to make new future business
plans
more likely with such uncertainty they
would start planning for an orderly
shutdown or for a sale
according to the majority amendment
during those 12 months various actions
by the puc and the department of energy
need to be undertaken as well as a plan
b developed
the last time the puc dealt with burgess
it took them 18 months to certify the
settlement
and then their interpretation of the
legislation was incorrect according to
the burgess power plant owners and the
original sponsor of sb 271
this plant is a 75 megawatt sustainable
reliable base load energy generator
capable of providing enough electricity
for 10 percent of new hampshire homes
it uses waste and low-grade wood that is
locally sourced
it is also certified to receive
renewable energy credits as an energy
generator
besides providing over 240 jobs in the
north country it also provides services
to the entire forest and lumber industry
which includes all counties in new
hampshire
it generates more than 83
are we getting to the point where you
tell us what your amendment does yes we
are
mr speaker
it generates over 83 million dollars in
labor income and the economy economic
activity in our state and even shares
its profits with the local host
community of berlin
the far too short time horizon uh that
is given by the uh by the previous
amendment and
in contrast to mine places these vital
elements of our state economy in
jeopardy
the existence of low-grade wood market
is not only an economic uh req requisite
for the forest sector but also ensures
the health and in a large part of our
tourist sector
currently it is the largest renewable
energy plant in new hampshire shutting
it down would mean turning our backs on
our locally based renewable energy
source and increasing reliance on fossil
fuels
my floor amendment provides 24 months
which would be an adequate time to
develop a financial survival plan
if we truly want to save this critical
energy so resource and safeguard our
major sector of the new hampshire
economy we need to give this plant a
fighting chance
and that is why i ask you now to press
the red button to reject
the uh
sorry the green button to support my
floor amendment and mr speaker i asked
for a
division vote
representative harrington is recognized
to speak against the floor amendment
thank you mr speaker
this uh amendment would increase what i
would call the bleeding that we've been
experiencing now for quite some time
with the burgess biomass plan it would
increase this
not 12 months as he was just stated but
the amendment has passed was 18 months
this would extend it to two and a half
years because the effective date is
november of this year and the date would
be a year from that under the
other amendment and under the one minute
we're talking about now would be two
years from then so that's two and a half
years now why do i say stop the bleeding
this plan has been in his existence for
quite some time it signed a contract
willingly signed a contract that it
pursued and now it doesn't want to live
up to the terms of that contract
the contract has now where they owe the
rate payers of new hampshire over 50
million dollars and it's time to pay it
back they don't want to pay it back so
their response was
have a bill which came out of the senate
which we were told by the main spawn
sorry the people on the other side of
the wall
i was told by the main sponsor that
whatever it takes whatever it costs we
need to do to keep this plant operating
which is obviously silly
this plant is not viable under its
present ownership giving them a year
from november is a gift it allows them
to spend a year looking into the only
viable option which is sale of the plant
this should not be a shock they've been
operating at a loss for as long as
they've been there and they will
continue to operate at a loss and that
debt to the rate pays will continue to
build up it's we've been paying extra
money and extra money and we'll continue
to do it the question is we do it for
another year from november or two years
from november
well i say the only viable thing is sale
when you look at the their report that
biomass burgess biomass just put out
they look at long-term solutions and
they say challenges posed by the default
service bidding requirements proved too
great
and they go on to talk about other
possibilities of using their waste heat
for various things and they say
the bottom line is
no one is willing to put capital at risk
to develop a project which relies on a
power plant with uncertain future in
other words no one will spend their
money but they want you to spend
ratepayers money on this
selling power plants is something that
happens all the time in new england i
think most of
the power plants have been sold
once or twice normally at a loss let me
give you for example the londonderry
plant in southern new hampshire it's a
natural fire gas plant ten times the
size of this plant
and that was sold basically the original
owners walked away and told the bank
it's yours we can't make a profit at it
it's been subsequently sold a couple of
times
and is now operated by calpine at a
profit so the only long-term plan for
this is sale
and they can work on that in an a year
and a half to develop people to come in
and purchase that is enough time it's
time to stop the bleeding the rate
payers have paid too much they're never
going to get their 50 million dollars
back one way or the other but let's not
add more to the bill and please press
red on this amendment thank you
the questions on floor amendment 1894-h
a division vote's been requested this
will be a division vote members please
take your seats
so
are you doing api
there'll be a vote
the question is on floor amendment
1894-h
representative samson is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr mr speaker
if i know
that there are two options here and we
just heard that
there might be an eminence sale
so if if
if i know that my floor amendment will
provide more time for this facility to
stay in
in business
and if i know also that this is the only
and the largest renewable energy plant
we have in this state it's an in-state
energy resource not an out-of-state fuel
source
if i know all that and i wish to keep
the plant open and not sell it would i
now vote
agreeing on the floor amendment
representative is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know the extension
that burgess biopower was granted by
senate bill 577 back in 2018
has given them plenty of time to come up
with a solution
to this problem
and if i further know
that giving them two more years
is not going to help them find a
solution to this problem because it
removes the sense of urgency
and finally if i know that adding
another year to this cap beyond the one
that our committee amendment provides
we'll add another 20 million dollars to
ever source ratepayers
costs for this bill
would i press the red button and vote no
on this floor amendment thank you mr
speaker
the question is whether to adopt floor
amendment 1894-h
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
okay
[Music]
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
143 in the affirmative 190 in the
negative the amendment fails
we're back now to the majority committee
report of octopass with amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
reports adopt it
all right
mm-hmm
also be in order
majority committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred senate
bill 2 424 fn an act relative to
renewable energy and natural gas
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass
john leakey for the majority of the
committee
majority of the committee and considered
the same being unable to agree with the
majority report with the following
resolution resolved that has been
expedient to legislate jim lucas parcell
for the minority of the committee
do you reckon
thank you mr speaker
for what reason to remember rise
oh i thought you were very sorry
you told me
okay i'm very sorry
i recognize european press
to speak against the committee report
yes
renewable natural gas is a bad
description for a worse idea
it's a feel-good green washing
of what is actually very expensive to
produce biomethane
in fact our current fossil drive natural
gas pricing would have to increase
six times its present level
to make biomethane broadly affordable
and then only a modest supplement to our
current depleting fossil fuel reserves
with methane leakage
at an all-time high this bill makes bad
environmental sense
methane is less than a tenth of the
total greenhouse gas emissions but pound
for pound
methane's impact
is 20 times 25 times greater than carbon
carbon dioxide
also there is no way to sequester
methane by compost or within our forest
unlike carbon dioxide
it is important to understand
what this bill isn't
there are efforts underway to churn
landfills to recover biogas one
application
is stated as a slated open in lebanon
where the biogas is directly converted
to electricity
arguably this may not be as desirable as
diverting organic waste away from
landfills
but neither is it what this bill is
addressing
indeed
this bill sets the definition of
mislabeled renewable natural gas to
require that the finished product
to meet pipe time quality standards or
transportation fuel grade
this will require dedicated and
unrelated unregulated
biomass gasification plants
highly susceptible to leakage and
potentially
financed at ratepayer expense
to the last point
this bill makes bad economic sense
it will be left to the public utilities
commission to decide if research
constructed
construction or production cost will be
shifted
from the utilities to the ratepayers
this bill pretty much represents a blank
check for biomethane production
if successful the industry shareholders
will benefit
if it fails
the ratepayers foot the bill
i know that many of us agree
this is not exactly how the free
enterprise system is meant to work
so i urge you to defeat the ought to
pass recommendation
so that we can reconsider our
willingness to engage in bad economics
thank you
chair recognize representative brezny
thank you mr speaker
senate bill 424 is it
senate bill 424 is an enabling piece of
legislation that would allow the state's
natural gas utilities to procure a
certain amount of renewable natural gas
known as
rng with pre-approval from the public
utilities commission
renewable natural gas is created from
decomposing organic matter
the gas which would otherwise be emitted
into the air as methane is captured and
purified so that it meets the same
standards as conventional natural gas
it can be created from animal waste food
waste landfills low-grade wood and other
sources
this legislation creates the ability for
gas utilities to incorporate rng into
their supply while also allowing the
state to benefit from local investments
local job creation and local energy
options
this creates a winning solution for new
hampshire businesses to invest in rng
market while preserving energy choice
and optimizing our existing energy
distribution system
this bill is the work product of a
robust group including the department of
energy and has brought bipartisan
support from legislators and stakeholder
groups alike
it allows the gas utilities to procure
up to five percent of rng with
pre-approval by the public utilities
commission and after demonstrating that
it is in the public interest to do so by
means of a public interest test
it also requires the utilities to work
with the department of energy in issuing
requests for proposal to procure rng
further this bill requires a study to be
conducted by the department of energy no
less than three years after this
legislation takes effect in order to
study all the impacts of this
legislation may have including benefits
to the state any impact to ratepayers
and an assessment of the existing rng
market
this legislation allows
the state to begin to explore the
benefits of utilizing drop-in energy
resources like rng
and how these sources can be green our
pipeline without a subsidy or mandate
and with proper guardrails put in place
by this bill i ask you to support sb424
thank you mr speaker
for what reason is it memorized
to make a motion mr speaker stage of
motion
i moved to table sb 424
and i'd like to call for a division vote
the motion is the table senate bill 424
this is a division vote members take
your seats
so
house will be in order
the motion is the table senate bill 424
this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative samsic
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you miss thank you mr speaker uh
honorable members
um if i know
that while i am a co-sponsor of this
bill
i have now come to the conclusion that
this bill needs more work
and if i further know that using
renewable natural gas from landfills and
other sources
could be a a very useful con
contributor to our energy future
and if i also know however that
considering the reorganization of the
puc and the department of energy it is
not clear that rate payers will be
properly protected
against investing in such
currently
not mature technologies
and finally while i believe we should
continue to pursue this idea i think at
this point it's not ready and we should
table this bill thank you
by pressing the green button
chair recognized representative roles
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know this carefully considered and
worded bill
is enabling legislation
that provides us with the opportunity to
create a new renewable resource
which is badly needed in our state
according to some
and if i also know that we've already
heard the debate on this issue
and we can easily make up our minds on
whether or not to pass this bill
but i now press the red button
to defeat this tabling motion so that we
can have a vote on the full bill thank
you mr speaker
the motion before us is the table senate
bill 424 this is a division vote you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your proposal press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
represent representatives
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
stay to the vote
139 voting 890 voting a the tabling
motion fails
the motion before us now is the majority
committee report of ought to pass on
senate bill 424 are you ready for the
question division has been requested
this will be a division vote
so
i understand
the motion before us is the majority
committee report about to pass in senate
bill 424
this is a division vote chair recognizes
representative pimentel for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that all the costs of the development
and implementation of renewable natural
gas technology will be totally
paid for by the ratepayers and if i know
that the cost of renewable natural gas
is up to eight times the cost of
conventional natural gas
and if i know that hp
424 opens the door to greenhousing the
burning of harmful methane gas
would i press the red button opposing
the otp so another motion can be made
thank you
chair recognized representative thomas
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that renewable
natural gas
benefits both gas utility customers and
the public and also offsets
and reduces the naturally occurring
emissions and waste streams
if i further believe and know
that this is consistent with and
supports the objectives of the new
hampshire energy
plan
would i then encourage
the procurement
and investments of renewable natural gas
resources
by pressing the green button and
supporting the bipartisan community
recommendation of otp thank you mr
speaker
motion before says majority committee
report about a pass on senate bill 424
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you opposed to press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative mcmahon
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
state of the vote
214 voting a 118 voting a committee
report is adopted
the chair recognizes the clerk for an uh
announcement
thank you mr speaker would the committee
chairs on their way out to lunch please
stop and see me for
senate amended house bills thank you
we're going to take a lunch we've still
got 10 bills to go
i thought we're going to be able to get
through them a little quicker
but
you have the lunch outside by unh so i
would ask everybody to be back here at
one o'clock sharp so we can get going
and finish up
[Music]
members take your seats
so
the house will come to water
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy which was referred
senate bill 448 fn an act relative to
energy reproduction by state agencies
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate j.d bernardi from the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
senator jacqueline kriegen in for the
minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
christian for uh to speak against the
committee report
thank you mr speaker thank you respected
colleagues this is a simple two-part
bill
the first thing that this bill does is
provides language instructing the state
to consider energy efficiency when
making decisions about renovating
constructing purchasing or leasing
buildings
if you recall just a few months ago this
body voted unanimously on a bill to
preserve the new hampshire saves program
because we all agree how important
promoting energy efficiency is to the
citizens of our state for both
environmental and economic reasons
ensuring that the state itself is
considering and taking advantage of
these opportunities for long-term
savings is an easy win
the other important thing that this bill
accomplishes is provides language
necessary for the director of the
state's vehicle fleets to take certain
actions supporting a transition to low
or no emission vehicles this is also a
bipartisan goal
touted by the governor in his state of
the state speech earlier this year
importantly this bill would allow the
establishment of electric vehicle
equipment and supply sites for state
vehicles this would allow state fleet
vehicles to serve as part of our energy
grid which is a critical part of our
grid modernization strategy
these simple steps make good economic
sense for the state
so most of us drove here today i know we
are all acutely aware of the recent
volatility and increases in fossil fuel
prices
taking steps to reduce our energy needs
and expenditures as a state should be
something that we can all get behind i
urge you to vote no on the committee
recommendation of itl so that we can
pass this simple enabling legislation
and i request a division vote thank you
chair the chair recognizes
representative bernardi
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker the focus of this bill is
energy policy is found in rsa 21 1
colon 19.
it declares the policy of new hampshire
to pry is to prioritize public health
and environmental quality while
maximizing economic benefits
through use of economical energy
measures in the construction renovation
operation maintenance of property owned
and leased by the state
everything from weatherization to
automobiles
the proponents of this bill
would mandate that all state vehicle
purchases or leases be zero emission by
2025 if feasible practical
and cost effective
yet this standard is not applied
throughout the whole bill it often in
various sections only requires
feasibility
the bill presumes electric vehicles evs
are the most economic operationally
efficient and environmentally clean
proponents fail to recognize
the acquisition of the raw materials for
batteries and evs
is intensively energy consumptive and
tremendously environmentally destructive
proponents will suggest that we should
reduce our reliance on out-of-state
energy resources
yet solar panels windmills and batteries
or their components are essentially all
made out of state
they would have a send our money to
china
and say that we're keeping it here
proponents consider evs to be pollution
free yet they ignore the fact
that the power they use comes
essentially from natural gas uranium oil
or coal
proponents further disregard that new
hampshire's electric capacity is
seriously limited during peak power
demands during prolonged winter cold
snaps
just when we don't need our emergency
vehicles
offline we have no significant new power
production sources coming online in the
near future
california the most
active advocate for transition to evs
now has to often tell their citizens
please don't charge your car right now
because we don't have enough power
we don't need to push our citizens into
rolling winter blackouts with a big new
fleet of state
run evs
finally and probably most importantly no
additional legislation is required for
any state agency to choose the most
practical cost-effective and economical
vehicles no ev mandate is required
please vote green to itless bill thank
you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
committee report have been expedient to
legislate on senate bill 448
are you ready for the question
the division has been requested members
take their seats
so
the motion before us is a majority
committee reporter been explaining to
legislate on senate bill 448
this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative
mcwilliams for parliamentary inquiry
[Music]
mr speaker
if i know that now is an opportunity for
us to modernize our grid right here in
new hampshire
and step boldly into the 21st century
and if i know that implementing this
bill will allow us
to save funds
across the board on state expenditures
for energy efficient vehicles
would i then press
the red button
so that a new motion could be made thank
you
chair recognizes representative host for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the state of
new hampshire has been implementing
robust energy efficiency
measures for its public buildings since
before i came became a member of this
body
and if i also know that the battery
accounts for 30 to forty percent of the
cost of an electric vehicle
if i further know that the price of
lithium carbonate which is a key
component of such batteries
has increased in cost from six thousand
dollars a ton in 2015 to a ridiculous 70
000 a ton in 2022
and if i also know that the cost of a 60
kilowatt hour battery sufficient
to power a large sport utility vehicle
has risen from thirteen hundred and
ninety five dollars to seven thousand
four hundred dollars in the last year an
increase of four hundred and thirty
percent
and finally if i believe that statistics
like these mean that the future of
electric vehicles remains volatile and
unpredictable
but i now press the green button to
ensure that new hampshire proceeds
cautiously down the electric vehicle
path thank you mr speaker
the motion before us a majority
committee reported
inexpensive bill 448 this is a division
vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
181 voting yeah 148 voting a committee
report is
[Music]
all adopted
so
majority of the committee on the special
committee of on redistricting to which
was referred the house will be in order
senate bill 200 an act relative to the
election of district commissioners in
haverhill having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment president
of ross berry for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment the recommendation
that bill ought to pass with amendment
senator paul bergeron from the minority
of the committee
majority committee re
amendment is 1702 age printed in house
record
pages 48 through 50.
chair recognizes representative abramson
to speak against the committee report
amendment
thank you
mr speaker mr speaker i rise
in opposition to amendment 1702-h the
so-called kenny mccormick district
as many members already know in 1812
democrat governor elbridge jerry signed
a bill
redrawing the legislative districts in
massachusetts to keep the predecessor of
the republican party or the the whig
party at the time from winning a
majority in that year
the top of the head
of that salamander district where we get
the american term gerrymander
is literally in my backyard back in
seabrook i took a look at those woods
while writing this speech looking out at
america's first ever gerrymandered
district
hoping that we could restore our party's
long tradition of the politics of
principle as president reagan often said
trust the people
for two centuries
jacksonian
democrats and big city party bosses of
both parties
gerrymandered states and but voters
supported republicans in an effort to
stop this terrible practice
technically it is impossible to
gerrymander one or two districts but the
public has rarely heard
this proposal of proportional districts
before the election
and were not given sufficient notice it
was only mentioned once or twice in the
news
neither the governor nor the senate has
argued for the idea of proportional
districts
nor even explained it to the public and
the governor's veto threat shows
no understanding in those public
statements of this approach nor the
important debate that's behind it
this i-93 district may come to be known
by the public as the kenny mccormick
district the famous orange clad
inaudible character from south park
which the district resembles
but kenny
in the show south park was always
muffled and died in each episode as a
running gag
and this amendment kills retail politics
in new hampshire by creating two long
boundary districts where candidates must
spend money in five different television
markets forcing our congressional
delegation to raise tens of millions of
dollars
from out-of-state special interest
groups
several years ago
i admit that i suggested proportional
districting to a committee of this body
and have come to regret it
after doing more research we've come to
find
that heavily republican and democrat
leaning districts around the country
produce the worst representation and the
least competition stifling the will of
the voters and muffling them in november
if these entrenched partly line
districts produce the worst beltway
congress critters
why would we create two more of them
why make congressional district races
more expensive putting our congressional
delegation in the back pockets of out of
state in and foreign-moneyed interests
that all four men on mount rushmore
warned us against
mr speaker
drawing another line in the sand won't
fix what's gone wrong with our broken
system of government in washington dc
a great line that wraps around
manchester resembling the wall around
ancient athens history's first democracy
or democratia
greek for mob rule
ronald reagan once warned that a nation
that cannot defend its own borders isn't
a nation at all
will a legislature that cannot meet its
constitutional and moral obligation to
craft fair districts
that inspire public confidence isn't a
republic at all
mr speaker putting kenny mccormick on a
congressional district map is like
putting lipstick on a pig
red
red lipstick red button
house will be in order
chair recognizes representative berry
thank you
thank you mr speaker
there's a lot going on there
mr speaker
this is my map
unlike the previous map where
i compromised and i tried to vote count
and do a map that would pass the body
this map
was a map that i developed
when i released this map
someone said i appeared agitated
and they were right
they thought i was agitated because the
minority party was attacking the map
they were wrong
mr speaker i was agitated because for
eight months i sat in hearings about map
after map and i heard from the minority
party communities of interest
existing political boundaries county
lines
competitive
and i was agitated mr speaker because i
gave them a map that did all of that
let's talk about the districts mr
speaker the current congressional map
splits five out of new hampshire's ten
counties the minority party thinks
that's a-okay
this map mr speaker splits two
it keeps eight
of the counties in this state wholly
intact a request that the minority party
asked for they got it
mr speaker this map has the lowest
deviation of any map publicly presented
there's
1.377 million people that live in this
state and this map has a difference of
nine
nine without dividing a single town or
city
mr speaker
this map recognizes the map that
recognizes the state as it is today in
2022 it is not my fault mr speaker that
the i-93 economic corridor is in fact
the largest community of interest in
this state but currently it is divided
it is pulled apart so that the seacoast
the second largest economic community of
interest as the minority party would say
can be remained intact so what does this
map do mr speaker it recognizes every
economic community and it keeps them
intact
my friends on the other side might
recognize that keeping communities of
interest together was a request that we
heard from this well how many times
and here it is mr speaker a map that
they asked for
and they got it and now predictively
the truth is revealed they didn't
actually want that what they want mr
speaker is a map that solidifies their
incumbents forever
a map mr speaker
that doesn't hold incumbents accountable
we just heard mr speaker about how we
want competitive districts
may i continue mr speaker
don't don't get into
the motive
of anybody else the other party or an
individual yes mr speaker i will i will
do that mr speaker when we speak of
competitive
let's talk about competitive
this map produces a congressional
district one where the winning party
would have won with
300 votes
50.05 percent
that mr speaker that is competitive but
once again
we say one thing and sometimes we can do
another mr speaker i present to you a
map that meets all of the constitutional
requirements a map with the lowest
deviation that has been publicly
released a map that respects what we
heard in the hearings
mr speaker
this is a map that represents new
hampshire from in 2022
not 1880
house will be in order
the motion before us is the majority
committee amendment
1702 h
i was waiting for that who requested it
representative barbara griffin requests
the roll calls that's it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
so
the motion before us is the majority
committee amendment
1702 h
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes senator bergeron for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this amendment not only
places both incumbents in the same
district
but it moves four of seven of the
republican primary opponents
of the last congressional district one
nominee into another district to the
benefit of that 2020 nominee
if i know this amendment moves a total
of 86 towns
and a population of 559 000 people from
one congressional district to the other
and if i know this amendment still moves
the most northern part of the existing
congressional district one in carroll
county to congressional district two
so instead of the north country being
represented in congress by both members
of congress the plan reduces that to
just one and limits their voice of the
north country and its residents would i
press the red button in opposition to
passage of the majority amendment
chair recognized representative lin for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this bill redraws or this
amendment redraws our two congressional
districts in a manner that meets all the
requirements that our colleagues across
the aisle said a fair redistricting plan
should embody and if i know that the
population deviation between the
districts is the lowest of any plan
previously proposed by any party or
group that is less than nine people
and if i know that unlike the current
map which splits over ten
over half the counties this plan keeps
eight of the ten counties together and
does not divide any municipality and if
i know that this plan keeps together the
economic community
comprising the i-93 corridor while also
preserving other communities of interest
such as the academic communities in
durham plymouth hanover and keene and if
i know that this plan places together in
the same district the three northern
counties
which have shared tourism environmental
and forestry related interests
and if i know that this plan
creates districts that are more
competitive than the districts proposed
by any other plan and ensures that both
of the major parties will have a
realistic chance of prevailing in
elections over the next 10 years than
when i pressed the green button to
approve this plan thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
committee report one seven
amendment 1
1702h this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
if all members president an opportunity
to vote house will tend to stay to the
vote
178 voting a 158 voting a the committee
report is adopted
bills on second readings opened a
further amendment
for what reason remember rise
uh to motion to print the remarks in the
journal
excuse me
wait to the end of the day end of
bills on second reading opened a further
amendment
minority amendment is one seven three
six h printed in house record 17 pages
50-53
the chair recognizes representative
bergeron
thank you mr speaker
appears in calendar page 50.
the amendment proposes moving the town
of hampstead
from the first congressional district to
the second
that's it
according to the 2020 census the
population of the existing first
congressional district is just 17
945 people larger than the population
for the second congressional district
thus by moving the town of hampstead and
its
8998 residents the resulting population
difference is just 51 people
an exceptionally low deviation
and thus more than 99 of the state's
population will continue to reside in
their current congressional districts
there were a lot of opinions expressed
during the public hearings that we held
on this and other redistricting bills
lumping them all together
from all the different redistricting
bills that were before our committee and
saying that that was the minority
position or or some other group's
position would be unfair and
inappropriate and inaccurate
during the redistricting process for
the congressional district
the health special committee held
listening sessions in all 10 counties
and conducted a number of public
hearings at no time did members of the
committee hear calls for the
congressional districts to undergo
radical changes
the proposal follows nearly 140 years of
precedence in keeping new hampshire
congressional districts nearly the same
geographically from one decennial
redistricting to the next so as not to
upset the and displace a lot of
residents from one congressional
redistricting period to the other
the districts will remain competitive
in the last 86 elections in the second
congressional district republicans have
won 71 times democrats have won 15.
in the first congressional district the
seat changed hands in six of the last
eight elections with incumbents losing
in five of those races
the current districts were created by a
republican majority ten years ago they
have been and will continue to be
competitive
the minority amendment would ensure that
every
announced candidate for new hampshire's
u.s congressional congressional
districts will continue to reside in the
districts in which they have been
campaigning
under the majority proposal new
hampshire's two congressional
representatives would be moved into the
same district
while four candidates for the republican
nomination in the first congressional
district would be swept out of their
district and moved into the second
district
thus strengthening the primary campaign
for the leading republican fundraising
candidate in the first district and
forcing four republican congressional
candidates to restart their campaign
efforts in a different district
the filing periods for declarations of
candidacy for this year's state primary
and general elections begins less than
30 days from today
every candidate should be able to
approach the election on a level playing
field
the focus of redistricting should be on
the voter and not be used to benefit one
party or one candidate over another
one of the great strengths of the new
hampshire political system is that in
new hampshire house and senate the
executive council the governorship
voters are able to decide every two
years whether whether or not they want
to keep an incumbent in office or make a
change
this amendment would protect the rights
of all new hampshire voters and
candidates to have a fair opportunity to
color our state red blue or purple
please press the green button
in support of amendment 1736
and mr speaker i would request a
division vote
recognizer senator barry oh does the
member yield to questions
member does not yield
thank you
mr speaker
we've already voted on this proposal
once we shot it down once
they referred it as the least change
method but it's not actually the least
change method it moves one town but it
doesn't get the lowest deviation
possible because you can move the towns
of campton sandwich all albany excuse me
bartlett hails and hearts from district
1 to district 2 and you'd have a
deviation of 9 which is what we just
passed
but mr speaker to the actual proposal as
a whole
this is a map
that divides five out of the ten
counties this is a map that divides
every economic community except for the
seacoast
mr speaker this is a map that was
originally designed in 1880 and if you
saw the map from 1880 mr speaker you
wouldn't recognize it the map from 1880
looks nice if the map from 1880 was
installed was it was passed today it
would be off by 300 000 people because
this map
doesn't recognize the fact that the
population of the state has shifted away
from the sea coast for those of you
history buffs i believe our state
capital used to be in the seacoast
but mr speaker while it's nice to go
back 76 elections the reality is we've
only had 10 elections we've only had
five elections under the current maps
and in those
competitive maps one party has won
90 of the contests that's what they
define as competitive and mr speaker
finally to the argument of
building districts around incumbents and
candidates
mr speaker that's a really interesting
way to go about it so every 10 years we
should build a district based on who's
running for office at the time for the
next 10 years if that's the logic mr
speaker that some people would like to
use that's certainly fine i will not be
building districts around incumbents and
candidates i will be building districts
that best represent the people and mr
speaker this map does not do that
senator church crested roll calls that's
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
members take your seats
so
the motion before us is the minority
committee re amendment 1736-h
is a roll call vote the chair recognizes
representative bergeron for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this proposal would keep
gail huff brown mark gilbane tim baxter
and carolyn levitt
four of the seven candidates currently
fundraising and campaigning in the
republican primary for u.s congress in
district one
within that district and not move them
into district two
and if i acknowledge that a candidate
does not need to live in the
congressional district in which he is a
candidate but i know that the last time
a new hampshire candidate for congress
lived outside of the district in which
he was running he gathered less than two
percent of the total votes
and if i know that this amendment as
opposed to the majority's proposal would
move just one town not 86 towns between
districts
would move 9 000 people not five hundred
and fifty nine thousand people from one
district to the other
and would move less than one percent of
the population not forty one percent of
the population from one district to the
other
would then i press then press the green
yes button to support amendment 1736.
chair recognized representative lin for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this the the minority
amendment presently before this body
contains none of the positive attributes
of the minority of the majority uh
amendment that we just passed then would
ipad and when i press the red button to
defeat this proposed amendment thank you
mr speaker
the motion before us
is minority amendment 1736-h
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
156 voting a 182 voting a
the minority committee report fails
question now is on octopass as amended
chair recognizes representative marjorie
smith
okay
okay representative margie smith and
representative berry
both wave off
the motion before us now is ought to
pass as amended
on senate bill
200.
are you ready for the question
a roll call has who requested the roll
call
representative griffin requests the roll
calls that's officially second it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
i'll do it
the motion before us
is the majority committee report of auto
passes amendment on senate bill 200.
this is going to be a roll call vote the
chair recognizes representative
espionage for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know the amendment we just adopted makes
radical changes to our congressional
districts that our constituents did not
ask for
and if i know that our a particular
constituent from newfields the one with
the veto pen has weighed in and said
this map ain't it
if i want the legislature to write the
congressional districts but know that we
can do better would i now press the red
button to vote against the committee
report which i recognize representative
lin for parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker if i know for all the reasons
stated just a few minutes ago that this
that the proposal before the the house
now is a fair accurate and entirely
appropriate uh redistricting with our
congressional districts would i then
press the green button thank you mr
speaker
the motion before is the majority
committee report about it passes
amendment and senate bill 200.
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed to press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
179 voting a 159 voting a committee
report is adopted
for what
reason does a member rise
mr speaker i got excited the last time
but this time i'm on the ball i would
like to print
make a motion to print the
debate in the journal
without objection
committee on transportation do which was
referred senate bill 447 fn establishing
electric
vehicle and infrastructure fund this is
without recommendation
for what reason does a member rise
for a motion mr speaker
stage motion i move the table senate
bill 447.
the motion is the table senate bill 447
[Music]
our division has been requested members
take your seats
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on senate bill 447. this is a division
vote chair recognized representative
walsh for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know this bill establishes a non-lapsing
dedicated fund for electric vehicles and
electric vehicle infrastructure and it
also gives the sole authority to
distribute those funds to the department
of transportation
if i believe decisions on spending money
state money belong in this room not a
room on hazen drive
and if i also know that a similar
language is already attached to the
10-year plan
finally mr speaker
if i know bill this came out of
transportation committee without
recommendation which is proof that this
bill belongs on the table would i now
press the green button
chair recognizes representative sykes
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
colleagues if i believe that given the
current state of the electric vehicle
industry
is so frequently changing and that is
both timely
and in my mind vital that we hear the
debate on this bill
and if i believe that the fair exchange
of competing ideas
is the foundational bedrock of our
democracy
and that for more than two years this
house through various
valid reasons has not been able to hear
and debate the important questions
before us
questions that our constituents have
asked us to discuss and debate
and finally if i believe that this trend
of tabling more
and more
bills is detrimental to all house
members and their ability to be fully
informed
about the issues
what i now vote read to oppose the
tabling motion
and mr speaker i think we ask for
division already we already have a
division yes we do
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on senate bill 447 this is a division
vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
uh
[Music]
representative testerman
paul members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend state of the vote
under an 83 voting yay 149 voting a
senate bill 447 is laid on the table
majority of the committee on ways and
means to which was referred senate bill
318-fn
act extending the hours in which games
of chance may be conducted having
considered the same report the same the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass is in a fred doucet for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being i know will
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
amendment
the bill is on second reading and opened
a further amendment
representing almi offers floor amendment
1627h
and
it's printed in house record 17 page 66
is recognized to speak to her amendment
if i can find it thank you mr mr speaker
on
those of you who are still interested in
retaining existing local control may
want to stay and listen but i only have
one page of 14 font plus a four line
amendment that i want to read to you
this bill is a dangerous intrusion on
existing local control rights for a
single type of establishment the poker
palaces
it enables new expanded hours for games
of chance
allowing facilities to stay open from 8
a.m to 4 a.m the next day a 20-hour day
the current closing time is now 1am
which is when the liquor
commission enforcers go home
because that's when you're supposed to
stop serving liquor
i want to read the amendment to you
because it has been misrepresented
sometimes
on
it consists of
four lines added on to
games of chance may be conducted between
the hours of 8 am and 4 am
the following day
and then it goes on as an amendment
provided that the hours in which a game
of chance may be conducted
may be further limited by duly adopted
municipal code ordinance by law or
regulation
to a specified starting time between 8
am and
11 a.m
and a specified ending time between 1am
and 4am
that is
you can limit it back to where it is now
if the municipality
has reasons to believe that it creates
difficulty
given the place in which the poker is
located
on
my community happens to be the worst
example of where a poker palace is
located
on
in terms of difficulty for
the city which is why i am here
local control over businesses hours of
operation has long been allowed by our
state
this bill includes no provision
authorizing local communities to set any
limits on this new 20-hour work day
some of these facilities are located in
residential neighborhoods
the proponents of the bill say that
towns can set higher hours during the
site
inspection or permitting process but
many towns including my city do not use
these processes when a new business
moves into an old building
when we reuse the buildings
there is no explicit permission in the
bill to allow the town to override the
law that this bill creates
if the bill passes as is local
communities will be unable to address
the concerns of nearby residents without
deploying the police in the early
morning hours until 4 00 a.m
in communities where the facilities are
next to municipal parking lots as also
is the case in lebanon
winter winter snow removal will be very
difficult without towing the customers
here's the um
the minority amendment simply confirms
the right of local communities to
regulate expanded hours of operations to
fit local circumstances
it only affects the establishment the
poker palace if the local governing body
decides that expanding beyond the
current hours harms the municipality's
ability to provide expected municipal
services
it brings back the limited right long
granted to the municipalities to set
reasonable hours of operation and mr
speaker i'd like to request a division
thank you
chair recognized representative obrami
thank you mr speaker thank you mr
speaker
first for the record there is no such
thing in our statutes that defines a
poker palace
these are charitable gaming locations
that are supported by our charities over
500 they're going to be increasing
because of some of the other things we
did earlier this year
so
this is an interesting situation where
the majority report was ought to pass
and the minority report was ought to
pass
with amendment we don't see this very
often so the way the procedure is we
have to go through the amendment
first so that's what we're doing and the
amendment replaces the whole bill
so i'm going to briefly talk about the
bill and the bill is only three lines
long so i won't be very long
on this
so
it is about the hours of operation of
our charitable gaming locations
currently
these locations may the
word is may may be open from 11 am in
the morning to 1pm 1am at night
the bill just changes that from 8am in
the morning
to
4am at night
okay it adds six hours
so
we discuss four things in the committee
why why do we want to expand the hours
while we heard testimony about hampton
beach during that during high season
if it's a rainy day we have we have a we
have a charitable location at hampton
beach right across from the ocean they
were saying hey we'd like to open
earlier and you know in that logic this
conway has a location as well matter of
fact there are 16 locations in the state
throughout the state
that are charitable gaming locations not
poker policies
so
so we like our tourists and we like them
to help contribute to the charities as
well as to the education trust fund
because that's where the monies go
we
rep my friend from
lebanon mentioned the liquor we did talk
to liquor about this yes they're open
they they allow pouring of liquor from
from
8 a.m
right now 8 a.m to 1 p.m or 1 a.m in the
morning
so the other thing we just the other
things we discussed is that we really
want to
do the six hours do we want to do four
hours we want to add two uh three hours
uh but we we wound up saying now we want
to we want to we want to add the
additional six hours then there was
discussion about local ordinances
when this came up
we
the executive director of lottery who's
also a lawyer
said municipalities already have the
authority to restrict
and the example that we use all the time
is salem where they restrict the
locations within salem where you can
open a charitable gaming location
so
we had all these discussions then we had
the uh we decided there was going to be
three amendments i i moved one amendment
i didn't move it i i came prepared with
it
where we would restrict the time a
little bit
i but i realized very quickly that i
didn't have the votes so i didn't move
the amendment in the exec session there
was a second one that wasn't moved and
then there was this amendment that we're
talking about right now
that was moved
but the committee voted this amendment
down
and
and we basically the conclusion was that
the municipalities already have the
authority to do these things that the
representative from lebanon is talking
about
and
we
and that we felt it wasn't needed to be
this type of thing wasn't needed to be
in our charitable gaming statutes
so with that i hope you all push the uh
red button to vote down this
amendment
and then we could quickly go to a voice
vote because both sides actually agree
to the underlying bill thank you
the motion before us is the minority
amendment 1627h
a division has been requested members
takes your seats
the motion before us
is the minority amendment 1627h
this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative almi for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i trust the towns to do the best for
their local businesses and citizens
but sometimes
need the ability to restrict in order to
do that
and if i know that this bill overrules
the existing authority of the towns
coming last to the legal system on
would would
wouldn't i press the red button
and
no wait a minute the green button
wouldn't i plea press the green button
and allow
the flexibility needed to the towns to
deal
with situations that only come up in
some of these towns
thank you very much
chair i recognize representative doucet
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know
local municipalities already have the
ability stated in this unnecessary
minority amendment and if i know
municipalities
one municipality's failure in
propositive planning does not constitute
a legislative action
and if i further know the ways and means
committee was offered this amendment
heard this
amendment and the testimony and voted
against it
and finally
if i would not then ensure that we do
not impose unnecessary inconsistent
and arbitrary controls on the over 500
local charities
that charity charitable gaming
assists
with our successful
charitable gaming model my apologies
would i not push the red button thank
you mr speaker
the motion before us is minority
amendment 1627 h
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
if all members president an opportunity
to vote also tend to stay to the vote
156 voting yeah 178 voting a the amen
amendment fails
the motion before us now is ought to
pass
on senate bill
318. are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee amendment is
adopted
committed report
representative declared a conflict of
interest and did not participate
committee on ways and means to which was
referred senate bill 343 enact
establishing a committee to study room
occupancy tax revenues and fees in the
formula for distribution to
municipalities considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate senator timothy lang for the
committee
the motion before us is the in the
motion is in expedient to legislate
on senate bill 343 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and commit a report is
adopted
majority of the committee on ways and
means to which was referred senate bill
3434 three five fn act relative to the
net operating loss carryover under the
business profits tax considered the same
report the same the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass from timothy lang
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate
representative thomas schamberg for the
minority of the committee chair
recognizes representative chamber
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i wish to make a motion
i'm sorry
i was standing here
one minute
thank you mr speaker
from the state of new hampshire
commission to study business taxes final
report
of october 2014 the following points
were presented
were written
tax simplicity is a good tax policy
the competitive goal of good tax policy
should be implemented where possible
because of this state's heavy reliance
on these business taxes
and the critical importance of creating
and expanding jobs it is incumbent on
new hampshire to develop its business
tax policy in a clear and consistent
manner
and finally take into account the
potential impact a particular change may
have on the state's revenues
four of the 12 members of this
commission are still active today in our
legislature
two on the other side of the wall behind
me
and two of our own house representatives
one representing hillsborough 41 and one
representing coast six
every tax law passed by this legislature
will in some way change our competitive
position with neighboring states
the tax commission pointed out when they
stated in their introduction
we took into account ways to ensure
fairness and equity in the allocation of
business taxes among similarly situated
businesses
entities and taxpayers
ensure clear
tax laws and synchronization that
enhances the growth of jobs
and income in the state
our recommendations therefore take into
account the potential impact a
particular change may have on the
state's revenues this bill which we are
pondering now
senate bill 435 fn is such a bill
one section which i am not against is
the change to single apportionment which
helps businesses that are required to
apportion their income
this is a good fix
even though the dra showed in a static
study
using current law and the expected
revenues to the state's general fund and
education fund over the next three years
would decrease by 37 million plus
dollars
by going to the single apportionment
change
this means less tax revenue
is good for business
now to the second section which wishes
to modify the cap calculation on the
population of taxpayers who utilize net
operating loss deduction called null
nold
for determining profits
under the
business profits tax
we the state of new hampshire run the
risk
of a negative perception of our business
tax structure among small companies
considering location two or expanding in
new hampshire by changing our cap
this proposed change in 435 of the cap
will have an adverse impact
upon a number
of the 72 thousand plus small businesses
in new hampshire who employ over three
hundred thousand employees
the present knolled cap is a hundred
percent
sb 435 wishes to change that
to 80 percent
new hampshire encourages new startup
businesses and entrepreneurs to locate
here
and supports the present small private
business employment environment
but many of these small businesses
historically lose money in the first
years of operation
or have a small margin of profitability
i am sure all of us in this chamber know
of a small business in our towns that we
represent
and many of these
businesses are just squeaking by to stay
in business
the 100 percent cap makes a difference
of staying in business
the present tax climate with a hundred
percent net operating loss
gives old and new new hampshire small
businesses a chance to survive
while the proposed 80 percent
cap will make them pay part of that old
100 percent in a bp tax effective
july 1st 2022
and will limit their future cap of net
operating loss at eighty percent going
forward
this sudden change is not what startups
or our community of small businesses
are looking for in new hampshire
they and all businesses want
predictability
in their tax environment
like you my fellow representatives i am
a strong supporter of small and big
businesses in new hampshire
we as a legislature have tried providing
the optimum business tax climate here in
new hampshire
because of our state's heavy reliance
on business taxes
there has been a lot of tax legislation
enacted these last few years all under
the heading to promote our new hampshire
tax advantage
those issues that have been addressed
and enacted include
a decrease in business tax rates
market-based sourcing apportionment
single sales factor
and increasing filing thresholds
and now another new hampshire tax
advantage would be fixing the double
apportionment
issue under senate bill 435 fn
but why now are we including an
enactment
of an 80
taxable income cap
on the net operating loss
from our present 100 percent the net
operating loss helps ensure that over
time
the corporate income tax is a tax on
average
profitability
when companies have a larger null
than what they can deduct in one year
most states permit them
to carry deductions of any amount
forward
to future returns
there are only three states that limit
the carry forward losses
illinois
pennsylvania
and new hampshire
no other new england state has put
limits like new hampshire
states that limit these amounts like
this senate bill 435 would like to do at
80 percent
are ranked lower in the tax foundation
report of 2021
new hampshire's rank is 41st out of 50
states
under current law
a small business owner of a restaurant
or a dry cleaning business or an
entrepreneur
can fully recover or utilize their net
operating loss deduction at a hundred
percent before reporting any taxable
income
but under this senate bill
bill 435 the utilization of their null
net operating loss deduction would be
capped annually at eighty percent of
taxable income
this change of the cap hurts the
profitability
margin
if there is any
of startups and our small business
owners in new hampshire
now by passing this bill we new
hampshire legislators
are going to make the small business
owner and the new startups report
taxable income
and pay the bpt every year
by reducing the null the net operating
loss deduction
from 100 percent to 80.
how do you explain this to your small
business owner in your town
how do you explain to them it becomes
effective
july 1st 2022
how has that small business owner
prepared
to such a change
businesses like predictability
not upheaval
if we enact the 80 percent taxable
income on the knolled
net operating loss deduction the tax
foundation business climate report of
supports the new hampshire tax
commission report of 2014 of which we
still have two members serving in this
chamber that our knolled
rules are some of the worst in the
nation
so why are we making our nold rules
worse
again i often hear
that we rank low
we are currently 41st in the tax
foundation's business climate corporate
taxes
even with all our recent legislation to
improve
our ranking
so why again are we enacting an 80
percent cap
some in our state legislature often
speak ill
of the tax laws made in washington d.c
and so i ask
why would we be agreeing with washington
d.c on an 80 percent cap
as this bill now stands new hampshire
would not only be keeping its
restrictive 10-year net operating loss
period
it would now be capping the utilization
of those net operating loss deductions
to 80 percent taxable income
making it more likely that some of those
nolds will expire
unused
that is a negative against the new
hampshire tax advantage
as a minority opposition on the house
ways and means committee
i proposed orally that the solution to
this sb 435
to enhance the new hampshire tax
advantage would be to decouple
from the federal tax cap of 80 percent
and remain at a hundred percent
i also proposed orally an alternative
solution for new hampshire businesses
and that was to adopt both the federal
80 percent cap
and the federal indefinite carry forward
period
both were turned down
and
i and then many of you who support
business communities where you live and
represent
can correct this negative effect on the
small
businesses by rejecting the present
ought to
pass 435 in conclusion
this bill is about three letter words
f i x fix
and c a p
cap
this bill is not critical
for passage this year
as the 2014 new hampshire tax commission
said
let's take into account the potential
impact
a particular change may have on the
state's revenues
let us stay with current law until a new
bill next year
can be brought forth to truly improve
the new hampshire tax advantage
thank you mr speaker
the member from sanborn representative
lang is recognized to speak in support
of the committee report
to 1. that was the vote at a committee
on this bill on ought to pass
i urge you to push the green button
thank you
the house will be in order i know i just
got here but still
the question before the house is the
majority committee report of ocha pass
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
reports adopted
all right the house will come to order
the house will attend to bills removed
from the consent calendar
the committee on judiciary which was
referred senate bill 399 fn an act new
title relative to certain provisions of
the fetal life protection act requiring
an ultrasound examination having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative kurt welper for
the committee
for what reason doesn't have a rise
for a motion mr speaker state your
motion i moved to lay sb 399 on the
table
representative osborne moves to table
senate bill 399. are you ready for the
question
all right this will be a division vote
members take your seats
strangle myself
so
you go second
oh
all right the house will come to order
the question is whether to table senate
bill 399 representative osborne is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that the
language contained within sb 399 is a
less complete version of a position that
was already taken by this house a few
weeks ago past the other body on its way
to the governor's desk and if i know
that passing this bill again or
less complete than the one already
passed would just end up with a
redundant bill that the governor will
have to veto and it's just a waste of
our time right now would i press the
green button to lay it on the table
representative weber is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i want to support the
delivery of appropriate and medically
sound health care for pregnant women
and if i also want to support
the unanimous 21-0 recommendation of the
judiciary committee
would i now press the red button on the
tabling motion
the question is whether to lay senate
bill 399 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
representative mann
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
177 and the affirmative 156 on the
negative senate bill 399 is laid on the
table
the committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred senate bill
429 fn an act relative to the site
evaluation committee having considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative legs berezni for the
committee
the bill is on second reading and open
to further amendment
representative oxenham moves floor
amendments 1896-h
found in your seat pockets and is
recognized to speak to her amendment
thank you very much mr speaker thank you
colleagues i will be brief
you may well wonder
why we are pulling a 20 to nothing bill
off consent but there really is a very
good reason this bill is simply not as
advertised and a rush to judgment on too
many bills in too little time without
due consideration led to this wholly
inappropriate vote count
first
sb 429 came to us as a part of a pair of
bills both aimed at a complete overhaul
if not the elimination of the site
evaluation committee
that committee is one of the state's
only institutions designed to provide
public participation in energy decision
making
the partner bill was even titled quote
establishing a committee to study the
feasibility of replacing the site
evaluation committee
why you might ask were there two bills
aimed at this same committee
well that title tells you part of it
it's a foregone conclusion they want to
get rid of it because it stands in the
way of fossil fuel expansion in this
state
member will suspend
as my good friend from walpole reminded
me earlier that we don't speak to motive
thank you mr speaker
but our committee was told there was no
contradiction here between having two
committees one setting up a committee to
study and one that gives a detailed
program of reforms
it was a little bit like the magician
waving his hand and saying watch over
here we're looking at a permanent
solution while they
brought forward another one which had
the reforms that the committee might
have come up with
belatedly we recognize this bill as
needing a good hard second look because
just maybe it's this bill that has
buried in it the outlines of the
permanent solution
this lower amendment focuses on two fees
that are part of the fates the fee
structure the first is for wind
this particular one thousand dollar per
megawatt rate came out of one
wind
controversy a very controversial
facility for
almost 10 years ago
because of that one anomaly
wind was stuck with this
disproportionate fee rate structure
so that a 1 000 megawatt wind facility
would be charged
2 million dollars under the new fee
schedule
where an equivalent 1 000 megawatt
natural gas facility
would be charged
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars or
a coal or an oil
ninety thousand dollars
a hundred thousand dollars two million
dollars a megawatt my friends as my
chair has told me is a megawatt no
matter where the electron comes from
in fact this bill
this so-called interim measure is
targeting renewable energy facility
and generation in this state
and we must challenge it here today
and then
second part there are two fees as you
can see from the floor amendment the one
was for wind
bringing it down in line with the fossil
fuel fee structure and the other is a
completely new category of fee which is
to apply to renewable energy generation
facilities across the board
solar energy storage green hydrogen
geothermal whatever comes up
and again at the twelve hundred dollar
per megawatt rate which came out of an
anomaly from basically ten years ago
with one win facility
no rationale whatsoever for
disproportionately charging renewable
energy siting and compliance and
monitoring at an outrageous rate while
fossil fuels are being coddled
why would this bill penalize the very
resources our 10-year energy strategy
prioritizes
as the solution to our outdated
overwhelmingly fossil fuel-based energy
system at a time when decarbonization is
the order of the day
renewables provide us with resiliency
fuel diversity increased savings and
security at the same time that they keep
billions of energy dollars circulating
in our new hampshire economy
growing local businesses and jobs
in short
as our ten-year energy shore strategy
emphasizes we need to be instituting all
measures possible to incentivize
renewable energy and reduce greenhouse
gas emissions across the board but this
bill does the opposite making fossil
fuel development cheap and pricing
renewables out of the market please
support this amendment
and correct the harmful policies
embedded in this fee schedule
and put the house on the record in
support of the site evaluation committee
and the clean energy transition
and i ask you for a roll call vote
thank you
representative vose is recognized to
speak against the amendment
thank you mr speaker
i rise in opposition to this amendment
this house bill of this senate bill
rather and another companion senate bill
were filed in direct
response to recommendations made by a
state evaluation study committee
that was formed
as a result of the passage of hb2
last spring
the site evaluation committee
met several times during the fall
i served on that committee and had
issued a report with several
recommendations
the bill that we're considering here
eight senate bill 429 and another senate
bill that we passed earlier
implement recommendations from that
study committee report
the subject of this amendment which is
the fee schedule that is contained
within this bill
which was revised by the amendment
simply took
the existing fee structure that's in
statute
and brought it up to date based on
inflation
the original fees were put into statute
statute back in
2015. it was time to update those that
fee schedule and that's what this bill
does
there was a new category added
as my distinguished colleague mentioned
a few minutes
but the same rationale was used to
calculate what the fees should be
for that particular
category of
application fees
all the rest of the
portions of this
rather extensive site evaluation
committee bill
were agreed on
by everyone
on the science technology and energy
committee it was a bipartisan 20 to
nothing vote
so i urge you
to vote no on this amendment
so that can we can move forward
with the important reforms that this
bill contains thank you mr speaker
representative oxenhammer
excuse me request a roll call vote is
that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members please take
your seats
so
here
okay
the question is whether to adopt
amendment 1896-h
this is a roll call vote
representative mcgee is recognized to
uh for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
and thank you colleagues
if i know that undercutting our own
support for renewable energy projects as
stated in our state 10-year energy
strategy report
is a short-sighted and costly course
and if i know that sp
429 without this amendment
sets an arbitrarily high per megawatt
cost
on clean renewable energy projects
10 times the fee
rate for gas projects
which also runs counter to that strategy
and finally if i know
that to help new hampshire
pursue energy independence
true market competition
and the lowered costs and emissions that
come from portfolio diversity
then would i now push the green button
to bring the fee schedule in line with
new hampshire's energy goals thank you
representative votes is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that the fee schedule update
that is contained in senate bill 429
simply brings those fees
in line
with what inflation has done to
our dollars since 2015 when those fees
were originally set
and if i know that there are substantial
reforms of the site invaluation
committee in the remainder of this bill
would i now press the green button
thank you
no the red button i'm sorry
yes the red button i'm sorry
but i press the red button so that we
can move on and finish this bill and
finish our work for the day
parliamentary inquiries have been so
helpful over the last couple of days
question is whether to adopt floor
amendment 1896-h
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
represent what's here
[Music]
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
158 in the affirmative 176 and the
negative the amendment fails
question before the house is the
majority committee report of ought to
pass are you ready for the question
some such requests for roll calls that's
sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
the house will be in order
he requested a roll call
everybody stayed in their seat i don't
know how long we're supposed to wait on
these and i have done it to the other
party too and i'm not going to argue
with you you want a division vote
this will be a division vote
members take your seats
what reason does a member rise um i
don't know if there's a set number of uh
seconds before you bang
i don't know the set number of seconds
before pounding the gavel but obviously
you have to wait at least a certain
amount of time for us to uh
you know get our elderly knees working
and stuff so you banged it i think about
four to five seconds so like i mean i i
stood up within the time but their
number
not having a debate on this and asked
the folks on the other side who were mad
at me on another occasion nobody even
twitched this subject is over
all right thank you mr speaker i
disagree but thank you
for what reason does a member rise
thank you mr speaker i moved the table
this bill
[Music]
so
here's what's happening
this is a division vote on the majority
committee report of otto pass
anybody doing pis
no
okay the eyes have been waved off
questions on the committee report about
to pass if you're in favor you press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
griffin
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
224 in the affirmative 111 in the
negative the committee reports adopted
the committee on ways and means to which
was referred senate bill 316 fn
an act relative to lucky seven licenses
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative
patrick abrami for the committee
the bill's on second reading and opened
a further amendment representative
abrami moves floor amendment 1889h
princeton house record 17 on page 66 and
is recognized to speak to his amendment
thank you mr mr speaker well this is the
first time in 12 years that i pulled a
bill off consent
but mr speaker this is a housekeeping
bill that needed a little bit more
housekeeping
one of the provisions of of senate bill
316 is the changing of the provision in
the bingo and lucky seven statutes
exciting stuff by the way
that all prizes of 500 or more shall be
paid by check
and that and we change that to all
prizes of 500 or more shall be paid by
check
excuse me we change it to all prizes
shall be paid in compliance with
internal revenue service w2w
2g requirements
and so
such required documentation shall be
available for inspection by the
commission in this case the commission
is the lottery commission
and it and then there's another i'm i'm
not going to go through it all but
there's another another section that we
changed and these changes were in rsa
287-e colon 9 roman 4.
so a classic housekeeping bill
and modernization bill
after the vote was taken in the
committee
it came to our attention that this
change was also needed in another
section of the law
so
i said okay let's do this for the floor
amendment that's all we did so the same
thing that we changed in the bill we
changed in the amen and the
amendment in the other section of law
and the committee's made aware of this
the committee is unanimously behind this
change so that's what you really need to
know so hopefully you can push the green
button on a voice vote not push the
green button let's just go to voice vote
on the green and uh and get the bill
done thank you
the question is on floor amendment 1889
h are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment's
adopted
motion now is ought to pass with
amendment are ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
reports adopted
the chair recognizes a member from
auburn auburn representative osborne for
the third reading motion thank you
resolve that the house now adjourn from
the early session that the business of
the late session be in order at the
present time that the reading of bills
be by title only and resolutions by
caption only and that all bills ordered
the third reading be read a third time
by this resolution and that all titles
of bills be the same as adopted and that
they be passed at the present time and
when the house adjourns today it be to
meet thursday may 12th at 10 a.m
the question is on the third reading
motion are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
okay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted
please don't leave we have two unanimous
consents and a couple of announcements
representative abrami is recognized for
an announcement
this is for the ways it means committee
members we're supposed to meet tuesday
and wednesday on revenues
i just i just talked to chris chase who
is setting this up we're only going to
be meeting on tuesday now so you can
clear his calendars for wednesday we're
just going to hear from the agencies not
from the economists in this next week
so for ways and means members just
tuesday you're free on wednesday thank
you
clerk is recognized for an announcement
thank you mr speaker uh two quick points
uh as we all know the other body is
meeting today and uh is amending many of
our bills so chairs please check in with
me tomorrow
and so that we can communicate about
amended house bills secondly
all those of you who have not visited
your mailboxes in the back room there is
a free antigen test kit in your box if
you would like it if not there is a bin
where you can deposit it thank you mr
speaker
representative espicia is recognized for
unanimous consent regarding cinco de
mayo
good afternoon i'll keep this short
because we want to go out if for some of
y'all who are in the area we have taco
tour over in in manchester which is
where i'll be headed later
but um as you know today's cinco de mayo
this has become an incredibly popular
holiday in the us and to correct some
misinformation on this holiday it is
meant to celebrate the battle of puebla
and not mexican independence day that's
on september 15th
the battle of puebla was fought on
may 5th 1962 between the army of
napoleon and the volunteer army of
mexico it was considered a david and
goliath you know until i heard
representative chris true speech
yesterday
where france wanted to expand the
monarchy into north north america once
again
a vastly underfunded volunteer army
fought and forced the french army to
retreat on that day um
following this underdog victory by the
mexican army the mexican-americans in
california were fired up they organized
themselves into political organizations
and these organizations called junta
sent support to mexico and they
advocated for the importance of
defending the union as the u um as the
u.s was in the beginning of the civil
war
they celebrated in 1863 and we continue
to celebrate for 160 years following the
victory at puebla
we celebrate the resilience and
perseverance of the mexican people who
fought to hold on to their young
democracy
so tonight if you're celebrating by
having mexican cuisine or margarita
remember the brave soldiers of puebla
and say viva mexico
[Applause]
representative wrong is recognized for
unanimous consent regarding teacher
appreciation
day
thank you mr speaker
a young man in my community was
diagnosed at age two with autism
his parents were told at that time that
he would never speak and that he would
never be potty trained
he now speaks he's potty trained he
and as of last saturday he is a college
graduate with a degree
in game computer technology
[Music]
thank you
this achievement once considered
impossible is due to his desire to learn
the tenacity of his parents
and the professionalism and dedication
of his countless teachers and education
support staff
teachers don't often get to see the
fruits of their work
the late new hampshire teacher and
astronaut christa mcauliffe once said i
touch the future
i mean i teach therefore i touch the
future
many in this body are former teachers
and while it is national teacher
appreciation week i want to acknowledge
you and all granite state teachers for
everything you have done
to enable students like the young man
from merrimack to fulfill their
potential
and i also want to wish all the mothers
a very happy mother's day thank you mr
speaker
[Applause]
representative osborne moves at the
house stand in recess for the purposes
of the introduction of bills enrolled
bill amendments and roll bill reports
receiving messages and forming
committees of conference are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
anybody opposed
the eyes have it the house is in recess
until thursday may 12 2022 at 10 am